two
hello everybody and welcome to the H3
podcast
yes sir it's a Monday not just any
Monday of course it is Juneteenth June
19th where we
where we honor um
I don't want to say honor but let's say
we acknowledge the day that the slaves
who were owned by George Washington even
though he was a father figure to them
uh that uh they were freed and uh that
is a fan that is a great thing and uh
honestly it's a new it's not a new
holiday but it's a new national holiday
since a few years ago
and I do think it's a good one in terms
of
I mean look at some of the other ones
like Columbus Day is total BS
hmm although I like it being branded as
indigenous people day I mean listen
they're we genocided like
100 million Native Americans they should
get at least a day off cheers my dude
you know
cheers my dudes to the Native Americans
cheers my dudes love you love ya no homo
no homo though
hmm
that's somebody that that might be
somebody of the year it might be dude
that might be the winner just for no
reason cheers my dude cheers my dude
cheers
[Music]
so good
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey who we love love love
but what I really want to say is that
while other people are taking the day
off all your favorite shows radio shows
everywhere around the world they're
saying it's a national holiday we're not
going to work today we spit in the faces
of those lazy
uh
[Music]
I'm just saying we're here we don't we
don't ever go away
actually at the end of this week we do
go away for two weeks right
far longer than anyone else's yeah
that's true
yeah but um that's kind of true yeah I
think white people should be working
today
um
and that's why we're doing this we do
hate ourselves as white people
um
so I have to agree with hey all white
people say wayo I feel bad for being
white as a matter of fact everybody say
wayo
all right okay I don't like talking
about this whole stuff get off it get
off of it but um anyway we have a great
show here today which uh for a change
and um love ya no homo today is our life
today's our last week before so this
Friday is our live show this Thursday
there's no leftovers because hey Hassan
is in Japan again what's the deal you
guys stay away from Japan
yeah that is the deal
so weird pan is all about the respect he
just likes being a homogeneous uh multi
uncultured or not uncultured sorry I
mean not mixed cultures like uh yeah he
likes ethnostics yeah ethnostics
I get it Hassan weirdo
and um yeah so this Friday I'm very
excited we've been putting a lot of work
in I'm very excited I think it's going
to be a fantastic show it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be a stressful week in the
lead up to it
however
it's going to be Banger there's lots of
surprises there's lots of guests there's
lots of bits and skits and sketches
it's our biggest live show to date
although it's probably the first time
we've done it in like a serious
I don't want to say the other ones were
not serious but this one is
more serious
1600 seats beautiful beautiful venue
[Music]
yes H3 podcast live at the ace theater
I was thinking for um the end of the
year live stream we should start looking
at that
um maybe
maybe next week
no I yeah I don't mean right now I don't
mean right now oh okay so we thought we
may have figured out the crashing thing
but I already see people saying crash so
sorry didn't work uh there was somebody
in the pre-show chat who suggested that
they were watching on other channels uh
stream which honestly is a little bit of
a betrayal and I'm kind of upset about
it but they were watching somebody
else's stream and they were also
crashing and then they turned off the
stupid react
thing where people spam the hearts or
whatever and that supposedly fixed it so
I turned it off I didn't actually even
know you could turn it off but I turned
it off today in hopes that that would
fix the issue but uh people I've already
been reporting crashes so rip YouTube we
are uh announcing that we are actually
going to kick starting tomorrow cheers
I'm [__] serious man
welcome guys everybody over to kick
today we'll be playing the new Lord of
the Rings slot machine
you shall not pass to Great bonuses
[Music]
um
it's so [__] annoying this crashing
[__] and I I tell them every week they
go nah you're lying
you're lying like Okay so let's so we
got a couple of uh good stories here
today first of all pearly just pearly
things Pearl Davis
um
we on Earth
yeah so at the end of Friday's show we
discovered that she has music on
LinkedIn were they all on LinkedIn is
that where we got all these yes yeah
that's so weird I wonder are we the
first to kind of bring this out from the
depths no oh probably I think so I
couldn't even find it on desktop I had
to look on mobile LinkedIn oh dude she's
not gonna like this one yeah I think
this explains everything I mean it's so
painful it's so cringe it's so funny I
was literally giddy looking forward to
Monday's episode because I'm so excited
to watch these videos with you guys
yeah I know
listen you it's on the internet uh
pearls
okay I know I'm just gonna get through
it together okay now let me hear her say
well yeah we got some tater tot uh
updates we got some
um Joe Rogan and Elon Musk bullied a
covet scientist on Twitter to the point
of somebody
literally going to his home doxing him
filming him on Father's Day
and then putting it on Twitter where it
probably has like 20 million views now
and Elon Musk has not removed it
it's stunning and vile
and lots of other really fun stuff not
that one but other stuff is more fun
than that although that one's
interesting speaking of interesting you
guys remember how I was going on about
Ryan Morrison being a giant piece of
[__]
and we were taught this is so [__]
good
xqc's 100 million dollar contract
we were all buzzing the whole internet
was buzzing about it hey I got it
okay
watch this clip and it's just I'm
fantastic how it all ties together
uh what else what else what else
hello
oh [__] wait wait who said 100 because
he is who usually said this rumor anyway
I've spoken to nobody about any numbers
I don't know
my agent did
ah he's watching right now Ryan
no he did not he did it quotes him
dude the idea that Ryan went to the
Press without his permission
I try to why xqc
you get what you get man I try to tell
you
oh [__]
you know and I know exactly what
happened this is in my opinion Ryan
Morrison I know what he did he got this
huge deal he goes straight to the Press
without excuses permission says look I
got this big 100 million dollar deal so
that he can get his name out there with
that big price tag and then hopefully
get more business right even though I'm
telling you that was all xqc right
cheers my dude in my opinion of course
but isn't that awesome the timing of
that is just fantastic
happened like the next day
love ya
Ryan ah it wasn't him it was
just whole goddamn name in the article
look at this
New York Times he went to the New York
Times
look at this
Felix a Canadian known as xqc signed a
two-year roughly 70 million dollar
contract with incentives that could push
you to 100 million said his agent Ryan
Morrison they gave his whole [__]
they told him every goddamn thing in
that contract
without asking him that's brazen
well
good luck trying to get rid of him now
um did you hear about the uh the new
twist in all this with his deal though
about
um potentially some of that 100 million
figure is in equity in Kick I did not
hear that because so he hasn't confirmed
it but somebody uh asked him about it if
he got equity and he was like oh I can't
talk about that and then xuc being xqc
like 10 seconds later was like they gave
me the option if I want equity and I
really believe in the product like he
basically seemed to say that yes which
so that depending on how much like the
equity part of whatever his deal is is
yeah so whatever percent of that 100
million is in equity you can knock that
figure down here's what happened
they probably offered him something like
really good between like 25 maybe Max 50
million match and they said or we can
give you 100 million in equity but the
what's interesting is Ryan going and
telling the media that [__] him over
so bad because now people are going to
think he's worth 100 million dollars
when actually he's just sitting on a
bunch of worthless equity
yeah I mean I have no idea what
percentage that is and again that's not
even uh confirmed oh apparently it was
uh he was talking to Pokey here it is
um can I ask you something Friends of
the show poke he would love her
look at what's on screen right now yeah
yeah no this is this is actually what
this man is worth a hundred million this
man is worth the same amount as LeBron
James apparently not or not but yeah
apparently not according to well if you
asked Ryan Larson who put this graph
together actually and gave it out to the
media I'm so curious series
um did they give you any Equity
um can I talk about that uh
should I talk about that that's a yes if
he said can I talk about that but you
don't have to I got the like I said you
were talking about I was looking up I
got to choose
no no I got I got to choose whether I
wanted
um some or not right oh probably if like
some of your pain
which is whatever but
yeah but the reality is is that I
actually believe in the product which I
generally do so I also yeah this is
something you say if you have Equity so
I believe in this product you guys yeah
it seems like uh less confirmation
Equity right means that if I go super
hard right I get a part of what I do and
I really believe that I've been
criticizing YouTube
twitch
um even with all the [__] up that
twitch is doing and the amount of people
that are going to uh kick by the way his
contract is non-exclusive if he believes
in the [__] why wouldn't you just go
exclusive to kick right though that is a
plus in his column is it not because
I mean if it's not exclusive and they're
giving him
yeah 10 million then that's that's still
a huge W I agree yeah although well yeah
I don't think he can monetize on Twitch
if he's right right
whatever
the chances of kick actually succeeding
is still like very very very low I mean
the thing is like if he had gotten
equity in stake
you know I think steak makes money but
Kik is the loss leader for steak you
know what I mean like they're not making
money there so no they're dumping
dumping money yeah kick well xqc is a
genius and uh
I'm sure this that Equity will pay off
big time yeah
yeah as you know all great companies uh
who give Equity to their Gamers to their
early users have done well historically
that sounds like a really good idea
is there some parallel that you're
alluding no but it just seems it seems
silly to like we are going to be giving
xqc and train wreck significant equity
in our business like that's really going
to help them succeed long term having
those Geniuses involved
all right there it is so whatever
um
some someone mentioned me on tigerbelly
with a young gravy I want to share
something with you and I don't want you
to be offended by it so um well I made
out with a girl on the road I think
that's gonna offend me yeah but but
here's what's going to offend you she
goes this girl goes there's three guys
on my list yeah right
that I wanted to hook up and you're one
of them which makes you feel good yeah
right until she said the next two and
then I almost jumped off a building
the next two was Oliver tree Ethan Klein
yeah that's rough
yeah I kissed him on the mouth yeah
thank you hey Bobby I hate to break it
to you bud
hey pal I hate to [__] break it to
you
but your old ass isn't pulling that
[__] much harder than me all right I
mean dude you're not done you're not Don
Juan over there
okay
give me a [__] break Oliver tree I
get that guy's busted his [__] right
that is offensive he's vile
but like come on dude give me a break
Bobby you really think you're out there
looking so hot
stop bro
the only reason one of these girls will
be getting with you so that they could
[__] put your ass in a convalescent
home in 10 years and take the money
old ass at least I've seen what a vagina
looks like
what is that one is that also the same
guy
is that the same guy oh my God yeah holy
[__] dude something that unfortunately
you'll probably never get to experience
just saying
cheers my dude
what the [__] is going on love ya
holy [__]
oh my God holy [__]
yeah so Bobby listen
get off your high horse all right
just saying
I made out with gravy what have you done
Bobby
loser
l
next let's look at the comments
everybody likes gravy's comment
okay here's someone says Bobby Oliver
and Ethan are similar font of man
I could see that if someone like one of
them they would like the others what
ugly pudgy funny men
first of all both of those guys way
shorter than me
that's actually true that's actually
true so that makes me already the most
viable out there
are you leaving that pack second of all
um yeah there's lots of girls out there
who are like my specific type of guy is
fat short
funny offensive weird guys
that's my type
people saying that font is Comic Sans
you guys are the comic sens of men thank
you guys that's really flowering
and experienced its gentle caress
bro
how many of these guys sounds did you
pull
we're gonna have to explain the
backstory on that there's about six of
them uh two clips six sound bites total
wow that's a high ratio dude that's a
great I did Cheers my dude cheers
by the way thank you to certain
ad3840 bro Ethan is so daddy why so many
people think he's unattractive thank you
although to be fair
it wasn't that long ago when I was
Humpty Dumpty thing on the tiger belly
podcast
[Laughter]
and that was not the sexiest photo of a
man and what does he do I'm a straight
guy so maybe my perspective was lost but
I always thought Ethan was a good
looking guy thank you to the straight
men out there
I was really surprised when people say
it's ugly or when he would say himself
he looks good
especially with the weight off
you see that Bobby Lee
nobody's saying Bobby Lee looks good why
is he getting drooped up with Ethan and
Oliver
oh so this person points out correctly
what about stavi
he should be oh that does the same he's
the same font as well he's that fonts
King he's you know what he's bold yeah
yeah he's bold italicized comic Sam yeah
yeah
anyway thank you uh thank you for
acknowledging me though I I feel good to
just be recognized you know
fresh and fit are out in the public with
just shot I don't know how those guys
walk around in public it's so
embarrassing to be them in fact when
they go out in public they wear their
own merch look at this idiot fresh and
fit Productions [__] out of here
he's hitting me with the Zach Lewis The
Wristband he's like hey just holding my
hands like a natural dude that's a piece
of [__] watch it is you can tell it
looks like a Rolex though no Ethan
you're gonna make me defend this dude
I'm gonna and I'm and I'm gonna defend
Ethan go ahead say it okay hold on I
know I know okay I know he's gonna say
and I got my room yeah hold your tongue
Dan first of all and then this guy who's
like he's the rich one apparently he
literally walk around with the shirt
that says CEO Network like bro you're so
insecure stop and the CEO to give him
credit his is nicer than uh the other
[__] they're both embarrassing yeah
the one on the left is wearing a watch
he thought it was a wristband coconut oh
no that's not a watch that's like one of
those like you went to a concert over
the weekend I think this is one of those
pseudo magnet things it's supposed to
like increase your blood circuit
circulation that's what I'm saying it's
nicer than the other ones it's a string
made of coconuts
coconut some Barbados yeah you're gonna
say oh you wear your merch all the time
this is like me walking around with like
a H3 podcast hoodie like hi I'm Ethan
Klein from the H3 podcast please say hi
and recognize me right don't walk around
my face okay
go ahead Dan is that what you're gonna
say
summed it up
but anyway the point of this is the fam
who is
hitting them raw with the regular
she flexing on him but that Vape knife
so shout out to this queen
[Laughter]
beautiful love that
absolutely love that
from development either
201 super spy we love you shout out
that's great you the best
Cheers my dude God these bozos are so
embarrassing what are you doing you're a
fighter now coconuts why are you making
a fist
yeah
he didn't know what to do with his hands
[Music]
you got to take like your homie and get
a nice watch and just stand like this in
every photo
[Music]
dumbasses
anyway I wonder how they feel about
their friend Pearl getting
oh I dude now let me hear you say I know
I know Nick Merks is back he's the one
who was started this whole uh
boys leave kids alone
he started this whole boycott
against um Call of Duty Call of Duty
because he said leave kids alone in
regards to duty
but in regards to a bunch of proud boys
showing up at a school board meeting and
getting into a fist fight right just
leave the kids alone yeah Duty so here
he is uh talking about it and then a
bunch of these articles painted me up
all a lot of the headlines said anti-l
anti-lgb bro
you don't have to be very bright to play
a Call of Duty apparently
he's having a trouble with that acronym
anti-lgb
you know that's what he said
that's what that comment was it was anti
what
how the [__] was that anti-l it had no
it was it's just listen I explained it
in great detail
I feel that if he wants to actually
answer that question
uh I went through the trouble of
explaining it so just watch the clip we
made I really do feel like it'll help
explain why
[Music]
these kids are very young
can't they just go be kids can't they
just be children
got nothing to do with that
I know we're putting them in the gay
Factory
no one should know that gay people exist
until they've been 18. this would be
it's actually abusive to even know they
exist so if you have gay parents I do
not want to hear it
keep that to yourself you little freak
I don't know man every headline said
that did you read them
so Jesus Christ man
I offered to have him call in all you
know what I mean but I shouldn't Focus
too much on that man I mean listen it's
true and then a bunch of people don't
think about that go back you know what
yeah trick shotting 360 no scopes
massive dubs you know High kdas that's
that's where you belong
you know let's not think too hard about
it he's right
um what was her name I'll tell you what
though
um Grace Van Deen could never
she wouldn't she would probably so true
she would think about it too much and
that's not phased at all I agree
uh yeah but Nick marks if you want to to
come talk about it I'd love to have a
conversation not even a hostile one I
just think it'd be useful for you to
understand at least why people are
saying that
but I like his act he's like actively
like I do not want to think about this I
do not know why
I'm just I'm gonna keep doing my trick
shots
and leave them kids alone
thank you
Nick marks ladies and gentlemen
oh [__] he says his son is dead to him
me too
because he went to Japan yeah I mean who
needs a reason
just because he's handsome and Tall it's
like enough reason
to hate him as any guy pull out and you
know I think up until that week Hassan
and I were you know we're pretty cool
and I know he's not going to lose any
sleep over our relationship or anything
man I'm you know I'm I'm not either but
after hearing him say what he said about
doc that motherfucker's dead to me oh we
got it right for God I DM him as soon as
I heard it and I said you know what have
your opinions we can agree to disagree
you can say the things you want to say
of course
but you're gonna go up there and say
that [__] about doc on his [__]
annual his anniversary right it's a
guy's anniversary
okay hold on hold on hold on this guy
would never survive a Cod Lobby are you
kidding me
what is what did Hassan say that was so
bad about doc
uh uh from the context I'm assuming that
he um talked about how he cheated on his
wife
thought their disrespect is more loyal
to Nick Merks than his own wife oh it
was on his wife's anniversary well he
didn't know that what the [__] you want
and also I mean really shouldn't have
cheated on your wife with all those I
mean listen when you girls when you
cheat on your wife very publicly and do
what he did you have to accept [__] for
that forever yeah forever that's what
she get you don't get to say don't joke
about this don't you just gotta own the
fact that
I've never seen anything like what doc
did in terms of the way he like went on
stream and started crying and [__] and
then I mean it was such a weird thing
I'm listening [__] like I'm cheating
right like I'm being a scumbag
and you're saying [__] like that
in front of all those people you're just
gonna let that rip yes all right I mean
[__]
you know I mean listen I'm not
you know like I'm not [__] showing up
oh I wanted to keep watching that's all
I want to just keep watching this genius
try to formulate words
okay well Nick marks as you can see is a
really growing from this and learning
which is all we could hope to do right
oh doc is turning on Hassan too he's
more loyal than yes he is more loyal to
he's more loyal to Nick mergs having his
skin than his own wife I know oh it
sounds like a comment like who's this
fat phony Hassan fat felony is he just
trying to like get at it because I guess
Hassan has like body issues
I don't know what if he like fat it's
weird Hassan Hassan oh the classic who
who is this person I've never heard of
this man before his his son Asin is it
pronounced heesen he sin
let's get it baby this fat phony he's so
concerned about everything he's
concerned about the two time and what
it's like
these people man you barely mentioned
you dumbass thanks
this guy wouldn't let
see he wouldn't see that's the thing too
like he wouldn't say these type of
things
if if we're standing next to each other
you know that's the most epic Alpha [__]
yo okay what you said
and it's true okay but if you you were
with me I would [__] hit you and you
wouldn't say it because you'd be scared
of me hitting you
you're gonna assault him that's what
you're saying that's cool I'll say it to
your face bro I don't give a [__] I
don't care about anything dude I'm crazy
like that call it right now you cheated
on your what you care more why don't you
just start [__] Nick marks
you know I don't think Osama would ever
see him in person because I don't think
he leaves his house for fear of the 5G
isn't he like a no I'm not joking no he
doesn't leave anymore I don't need the
rim shot oh that man I'm sure he's no he
like thinks that like 5G will give you
cancer or something and uses like
crystals to block the signals maybe he
just puts crystals in his shoes and
stuff
oh maybe it's like a mobile setup like a
mobile streaming setup yeah just
Shanghai yeah is Shanghai a real mineral
what I thought that was a joke thing and
I think Shanghai is a real thing I don't
think it blocks a 5G uh mind control
waves though
um
okay well DACA is pretty big though well
I do wonder what a scrap between the two
of them would look like here on Amazon
you can buy a shungite stickers for cell
phone production stickers six at a time
and 25 bucks
wow I'm sure the people selling you
those are really [__] happy you're an
idiot
um who would win in that fight though I
mean Hassan is massive and he's very
strong
uh but Doc is also very tall I mean he's
skinny but he's he's athletic how tall
is a doc like six eight six seven six
six it's taller than his son he's tall
as [__] yeah he's definitely taller than
this one
hmm when he came to the office
yeah I don't know it'd be a good crap
for sure
yeah I mean that sounds right maybe six
his head was like scraping the ceiling
of our office when he came home yeah
it'd be a good scrap he wouldn't
think we're clear because you know he
knows there's repercussions
I would hit him you guys I would
literally hit him if he made that joke
near me
okay emotional
sound like a baby
there it is oh he's not that much taller
than me
uh I mean he is but like can you
in the photo
he's not six eight
I think he might be that tall I remember
him being enormous
um
cheers my dude
yeah
Hassan could push him to the ground
though but he's quit the thing is yeah
Hassan's got girth he's probably got a
lot of pounds on him but Doc is he's
very athletic
and he's he's quick
he's oily
you know it has repercussions cheating
just saying
you know
it's easy not to cheat on your wife bro
and then to
emote it to the whole world okay
whatever moving on acoustic version
acoustic
xuc learning set as agent Ryan ruined
the deal we love that
DJ Khaled eats [__] after trying to Surf
okay first of all surfing is very hard
so I'm gonna even give him give it up to
our boy for getting out there on the
water
thank you
[Music]
oh [__] he was doing the hydroplane yeah
okay I've tried that's just not easy I'm
be honest that's impressive the fact
that he even got that getting up yeah
yeah like
not bad Khalid
it's not that bad for Khaled everything
he does turns into a meme another one
he just crashed on the hydroplane
give the man a break
thank you though I'd love to see it love
you
no homo no homo um
oh oh by the way this is my Father's Day
present from Teddy oh that's cute
I'm gonna show them that I'm wearing it
on the show
pretty cool
pretty sick
I hope everyone had a good Father's Day
by the way I did
really good I had one of the best steaks
of my life man it was crazy dude crazy
it's just massive massive rib eye that
we threw on the charcoal
yeah
my whole family was there it was a great
day it was it was a fantastic day you
guys all have fun Father's Day all of
your father's yeah I was with my Daddy-o
my Daddy-o yesterday Brandon fan of the
show that's right that's right Dan's dad
cool dad now
fantastic
all right
[Applause]
oh someone's asking for health updates
I don't have any health updates
oh I just got a message
I've been checking all morning
I got a new message all right let's take
a look
I've been I've been I'm here
so I have two doctors I've got my
general doctor and my hematologist now
and I've been messaging them both
panicking
so let's see who got back to me
who won
let's see
in the meantime oh yeah and then my
other doctor because you know I have
this dude I'm so [__]
no so you know I have I talked about
this I have this issue where I get
drowsy on the road
and it's like I can't help it it's scary
and I've been like this for a long time
or it's just when I'm driving
and I get so drowsy it I cannot snap out
of it it's [__] scary as [__] and so
I told my doctor about it I was like
maybe there's something I can do about
it he goes oh yeah I think you have
narcolepsy
narcolepsy he goes yeah you have
narcolepsy I think
isn't that that's not well I don't I I
thought that narcolepsy was that you
like fully passed out not just
apparently apparently it can just be
drowsy huh but the thing is if I wasn't
fighting it with all my will I could
fall asleep in like five seconds what
time do you go to bed
that's a great question to you wow uh I
don't know changes per night I do get
I'd get a decent amount of sleep though
I don't think I'm sleep deprived
did you go to bed at 9am this morning
9 A.M no okay because you sent a message
at 9am and we were actually wondering
earlier oh no no no no I wake up at nine
because the kids are super loud and
stuff and then you went back yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um he goes you either have um apnea
sleep apnea or narcolepsy I don't have
sleep apnea I don't snore I don't gasp
uh I'm a beautiful breather I'm A
Perfect Sleeper
beautiful no problem with the sleeping
Champion sleeper I'm a beautiful sleeper
no snoring the best to ever do it so now
he says I gotta go see a [__] sleep
oh yeah now I gotta go see a sleep
doctor
I mean my I'm so [__]
what is not wrong with me okay now he
says regarding the labs
he says some of these findings I don't
even know how to interpret because I
guess
it's not a specialty he's just a general
doctor
uh he says but the a a is something
interesting
take this with a grain of salt
with all the patience symptoms before
interpreting it no
seems like the biggest symptoms you are
experiencing is GI related
my poops have been pretty decent lately
just because they clog doesn't mean
there's anything wrong with it right
is clogging a toilet a symptom of some
illness no
I mean
massive doodus
could be
big old stankin doo-doos
well what you get sick and then you
generate [__] out of thin air
I mean
uh let's see I think we are looking for
a plausible GI issue that they need to
be real as some of these diseases can
Elevate n a a n a
like possibly the esophagitis
Vegeta s esophagitis
right here let me let me see China let's
go vagina-ish
it sounds like I've seen what a vagina
looks like these message is not he's not
afraid I'm dying yeah right
not good news
yeah I'm waiting for the hematologist
but he he he made me feel better on
Friday when he messaged me
he says uh I don't think this is a new
and separate problem than the one we
discussed
however if you develop fevers joint
pains rashes or oral ulcers
then let me know because
then that reflects
a bit of inflammatory uh
rheumatoological condition so okay she's
also died
there it is
fantastic
cheers my dude I love my doctor by the
way he's so awesome he's so nice so nice
to have a good doctor who like
I just trust his I don't trust him that
he knows what he's talking about and
gets back to me and sheep
I trust him
I think you can too
[Music]
that's what I'm saying I'll give you
guys his name and I get a kickback only
for every new uh patient I get
100 bucks
um
what do you what'd you say uh I'm saying
everyone crushed like now like everyone
everyone is Banning it I've never seen
it that spot so well that did not work
then I think we can officially say
everyone
I don't know what what can I do I can't
tell them we just have to keep harassing
them until they do something we sent
them a video well they're here let's
send them our it does sound like it's
confirmed to not just be us like this is
a wider YouTube issue but they they
don't they refuse to acknowledge it they
can't they just say nope it's not
happening
uh oh and someone says I have esophageal
esophagealis and acid reflux
it's pretty consistent with your
coughing up
oh yeah so they said I would get an
upper Endo endoscopy so that's what I'm
doing I'm gonna do that's scheduled
okay
that's when they stick the tube down
your throat right yeah we talked about
that where it goes all the way down to
your [__] intestines nice I did that
last year
because of my choking oh yeah what was
it like dude they gave me uh Fentanyl
a while dude they gave Ela fentanyl when
they did the egg retrieval a tiny tiny
bit a very tiny bit but like uh she's
like
I was like what's in her IV bag she's
like fentanyl I was like the [__] you
say yeah but she's like no no it's like
one
Nano fentanyl is forward is it not yeah
it's a painkiller it's like a mega
opiate right so like but meaning like
it's not actually that unusual to use it
in a medical apparently not I didn't
know people abuse it but it's yeah so
wait did you feel it no I just I knocked
out instantly but I do remember at one
point and I don't know if I'm making
this up but I remember them pulling the
tube out oh for a split second the way I
remember it sort of like the Matrix when
they're pulling that [__] two yeah
but it was like
very like Split Second like I was still
look at your tight little throat closed
up on that maybe
good you did that though yeah no I'm
glad I did too because I was worried the
audience was scaring me a little bit I
mean I know they were trying to help but
it didn't worry me all right by the way
it could be the 40K curse I don't know
where again every time we get close let
me tweet there was crashes happening
earlier too okay fair enough when we
were much lower okay so at Team YouTube
hear what you tweet that hi again it's
happening
worse than ever
yeah go ahead Dan I just wanted to catch
up on some of these super chats because
there's a bunch of them go ahead morning
uh let's see here's the beginning Blake
says cheers my dude thanks for the five
bucks Blake uh Lewis I hope this episode
is good I can't stand Dan thank you
Lewis
the nuclear soda just says fungir thank
you the new peeler soda uh Sydney says
endure
uh KP here's an interesting one 20 bucks
uh KP said broke down bathroom door A B
I couldn't have done this without you my
mom was trapped in the bathroom and I
busted down the door in three hits she's
mad we have to replace it because it's a
custom size I hope you see this yellow
this dude saw our episode and his mom
was like can you help me out of here
immediately yeah no problem
I love that nice KP uh Tatiana said um
oh we can debut some new sound bites
here Tatiana said it's my 22nd birthday
today no more 21. Zach would you be so
kind
thank you much yeah we got him saying
every number actually so not just 21 now
Aiden Ross is yeah I just tweeted from
my main account if anyone wants to go go
retweet that yeah yeah uh Nat said uh
it's also my girlfriend Coral's birthday
please shout out what you didn't say how
old she is so we can't do the thing
really nah really you're gonna forget
the number I appreciate the ten dollars
but not
ah well shout out Coral either way happy
birthday let's pick one through uh say
she's 26. yeah six
okay
26. [__] you
that one needs a little work they're all
kind of a little weird yeah what are you
gonna do weird and one last uh I mean
it's not the last one but oh before we
move on Stein donated 20 bucks said this
is my last podcast before I'm 22.
Zach I need this oh so he wants the he
wants the OG he wants we need
documentation we've been through this
yeah we did mention somebody posted
their ID on the subreddit
but I don't but I don't know who they
are so they weren't Stein necessarily
but yeah we need documentation I'm sorry
you only have one day so you better get
to that you better get on that quick
yeah uh by the way I weighed in at I'm
in the 203 range
[Applause]
twisting very very there's no chance I'm
gonna make it on the for the live show
but maybe as I could by the time break
is over you almost assuredly will yeah
that's a great comeback I think so by
the time we come back there you go
I made a promise promise is kept
our promises made Promises Kept there
here is uh here she is Zach I don't know
if this is proof enough for you
this is my 21st here's her ID and every
single one says her 21
year olds you think they're in this town
what the [__] he makes a good point he
makes a good point uh 2002. all right
well happy birthday to you 21. [__] you
all right nice there you go Sherry
that one goes out to you girly shut up
um all right uh we're at 44 minutes we
should do our ad we have one already
already
thank you to PayPal honey who we love
love love love love love
I love me some PayPal honey and I would
not use the internet without it and
neither should you here's a great thing
about PayPal hunting amazing service
free
easy to install is going to save you a
ton of money effortlessly and
supports the show
here are all genuine savings
from Ela or people in this office that
we've pooled
just this song's sick dude
that's just five out for a second
[Music]
slow jazz H3 yo
oh
that drummer's in the pocket though
[Music]
yeah Honey's the best
uh it works immediately it scours the
internet for the best coupon codes
available for the website you're buying
on
and it automatically applies it to your
cart at checkout imagine this shopping
at one of your favorite sites and when
you check out the honey button appears
and all you have to do is Click apply
coupon wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons it can find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon what happens
magic the price drops instantly
incredible yeah it's incredible wow I
mean it works on
all different ranges all different
flavors of websites all different things
so funny we're so synced up Zach
gotta be man you are so fat like it's
awesome
clothes Tech food pizza
Furniture it's all there man
with honey
every damn time
yeah so honey doesn't just work on the
desktop now either it works on your
iPhone too just activate it on Safari on
your phone and save on the go so that's
a big one
yeah getting honey seriously only takes
a few seconds and by getting it you'll
be doing your self-assault and
supporting the show thank you guys get
PayPal honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you so much to honey and
thank you guys
uh for considering uh supporting our
sponsors thank you
okay
who made this do you have the name in
there
um this is from epidemic sound uh Richie
Everett um
no no no it had an H3 thing where it
goes but it's not an H3 thing no sir
it's just a I uh synthesizer with like a
uh um
like you can pitch it
oh wow
very good like I I classifies it as like
a uh George Benson vibe
thank you
so uh where were we
where were we talking about Father's Day
or some [__]
we were kind of done I think it's time
to move on what were we talking about
though
you were talking about whether or not
you were dying yeah
so yeah it seems like cancer is not
super likely which is a relief obviously
that was what I was really worried about
that's great
well you've inspired me I'm going to get
a full panel checkup over our uh our
break so I hope all you guys go do it if
you can
because uh it's really important you
just go in there it's easy once a year I
mean it could save your life genuinely
it could save your [__] life
thankfully we have good health insurance
thank you you're welcome yes and uh well
hopefully you guys do too
otherwise then I guess you're just gonna
have to [__] die broke and without
doctors
I die Jesus
I mean that's how we live in this
country you know what I mean you can
afford a blood planner or you can't
right and if you can't afford a blood
panel just [__] die
love ya no homo
all right so let's keep going we all
guns good [__] here uh dripped out
Kenneth Copeland
who's gonna die soon hopefully too join
his bestie and uh
hell Hallelujah who's the guy who died
recently Pat Robertson yeah yeah Pat
Robertson did they were they friends I
feel like they would have been friends
uh I don't I have no idea I'm sure they
were in some demonic I'm sure they've
met let's put it that way demonic Circle
yo check out this drip bro this is
straight up what the uh mom and dad and
apple pie guy was wearing
it's God
Abram Abraham
Isaac God Abraham Isaac
Jacob became Israel
Jesus and George
you know it's fun like these people
George
who's George
he's gonna he's gonna go on to explain
but I do you want a spoiler no but
here's what I'm these people they talk
about the same thing every [__] day
like don't people get bored
like I get it which I think people do
get bored in church
um yeah that's definitely a thing he's
wearing a fun jacket that's why they
have to fun it up that's why they have
uh music and um you know a pulley system
for the for the minister to be flown
around the crowd they need new material
uh well there's a little thing called
The Book of Mormon and that is that's
the next that's the next chapter
actually the Quran too it's technically
the next chapter okay so that's all for
the next episode The Next Episode right
actually when we read Dr Dre style yeah
so here are these the demons together
happy birthday to Pat
blue demon
pep you demon they ref oh Kenneth
Copeland and Pat Robertson reflect on
their friendship oh well there you go
beautiful beautiful men beautiful souls
this nation particularly to Christian
people should be completely totally
based on what George Washington said to
Jesus Oh George
the first my favorite business Congress
George Washington and Jesus were friends
number one is that what he's saying no
he was naming all of the most important
uh you know prophets or or Scions of
divinity in order
and then uh leading up to George
Washington he said they talked here
first
Congress
[Applause]
number one
the First Act of Congress
was to enter Covenant with the almighty
God no it wasn't
I guaran [__] tea George Washington
never said any of that [__]
uh well George Washington was uh very
devout but he was also pretty strongly
in favor of a secular government and he
didn't enter a covenant with God no it's
not just George Washington he made a
very specific claim there it was the
first act of Congress was to enter a
covenant with God that is oh that seems
fact-checkable not what's that thing
about separation of church and state
yeah I mean that was obviously the
principle that a lot of accounting
fathers believed in and uh
let's see contrary to cope well here let
me finish it
great band they're like yeah so let's
see contrary to Copeland's assertion
Congress never made any such Covenant
with God not in its official capacity or
as a legislative body nor
during the Divine service that followed
Washington's inauguration which was
presided over uh by Reverend Samuel
Provost
who cares while it's true that George
Washington and his inaugural uh remarks
Express gratitude to the almighty being
and the great author of every public and
private good he did not even mention
Jesus or Christianity take that [__]
out they just lie they just say anything
as you all know Jesus George Washington
said Thank You Jesus God bless all
Christians was the first words he said
in this great nation he was actually a
George Washington was Jewish George
Washington's team
as you all know Abraham Lincoln as he
set free the slaves said
under the covenants of God
uh free these slaves and if you all
shall ever not donate money to Kenneth
Copeland's Ministry
you should be damned for all eternity
quote Abraham Lincoln speared to death
so angry in that
boy you're bald
it's nice to be able to just say
anything about anything
what a nice uh treasure to have Van
Halen played at the first inauguration
ceremony they said Thou shalt shred for
God
Hot for Teacher was the Gospel
that's right amen Amen brother
I tell you what man as George Washington
once said
thy wife shall submit to any sexual
request
I have right isn't that right wife
George Washington said that um
all right thank you Kenneth Copeland you
[__] demon freak psycho
golly
that's good
that's what he says when he's getting
blowed that's
different
all right that's good Jesus that's it
terrifying imagine you're blowing
Kenneth Copeland uh
no think about it then that's muggy down
there it is once a week I want you to
picture you every day I come home and
imagine Kenneth Copeland getting a
[__] and then think about how
grateful you should be
friends and then he goes
back to this he goes it's mugged down
there and then have quartering say you
know about that crotch Rock and it gets
muggy down there
you know you get that crotch rot oh yeah
oh no mug it down there
uh we love it on there we uh we kid
cameras we love Kevin
uh JLo and Ben Affleck are back and
posting
daddy appreciation post oh that sounds
wholesome Jesus what a [__] thirst
trap why did you unmatch me okay but on
the real though that's kind of
impressive how old is he
uh he's probably in his 40s
I think he might be close to 50. it's
50.
damn is he on something he doesn't look
like it he looks pretty Natty [__] I
think he's just in good shape good for
you man Batman
also um
Olivia pointed this out earlier but is
that a cropped nude that she posted good
question oh yeah hold on he's hanging
along oh this is part of the phoenix
tattoo I think
oh [__] you're right here you're so
right he's in the nude except for the
Phoenix wait I wonder if the Phoenix
wraps around and calls around his dick
he's hanging dong dude yeah he could be
he could be hanging down I want to see
the dong dude take it to Twitter
it's just so funny that she posted it in
in slideshow for Father's Day
she goes happy daddy appreciation post
and Happy Father's Day to all the
amazing Papas I mean do they have kids
together
no they both have kids separately oh
okay if you're trying to honor your
significant other for being a great
father
while I appreciate he is in very good
condition physically I don't know that
this does what she's attempting to do
that photo screams dad
it does say Daddy yeah
maybe that's the joke I don't know
no sound
that's just such a funny slideshow
I'm so glad they're back God it's like
all the planets are back alive she could
have put that one first that yeah
yeah wait what I literally didn't what
is their compound name again
I was trying to think of it earlier and
none of it BJ making sense
BJ
what's he doing here I want to see his
office you know what I'm talking about
right that's true yeah oh okay I know I
was trying to do it in my mind with
their last names which is not nearly as
easy yeah it's also interesting
Lopez I like that actually
his last wife Jennifer Garner her name
is also Jennifer so I wonder were they
called benefits family Jen
it doesn't work out so good it's me
it's why did you unmatch me
it's me I still can't believe that that
is the girl that married Jason now
she ghosted Ben Affleck for Jason
someone posts that to the sub at least
like once a month they say can you
believe Jason Nash I mean Jason's ripped
no for real he looks great no but I mean
just yeah what she [__] up so bad not
Ben Affleck I think she met them both on
Raya yeah must be two very different now
she went for okay
I totally respect she knows what she
needs she knows what she wants yeah I
mean that's fine yeah maybe to be fair
the personalities could I mean Ben
Affleck can't be that [__] fun to
hang out with based on his back tattoo
yeah you know what
I don't appreciate the Affleck slander
I'm a fan
me too
I'll say it this down yeah he's a he's a
great actor good director Goodwill
Hunting he's got a good sense of humor I
mean what's what's not the like
Jason Nash is a tour de force I think I
think I think Jennifer Lopez should be
with Jason Nash
your fault
I think her I think her vagina is
literally incapable of having sex with
Jason it has a defense mechanism where
it like turns into like a venus fly trap
mm-hmm
that's crazy I just I just I don't know
it but I think it to be true
cheers
[Music]
that's awesome so anyway moving on from
that so happy Father's Day to the one
and only Ben Affleck this is one of the
best things I saw over the weekend
Island Boys
the island boys
oh is this what I think it is yes are we
100 sure this is real oh yeah no it's
real because there was just the thing
with them on like Epstein Island and it
was like a no it's real AI thing this is
real I go to their Twitter it's 100 real
what's your argument their Twitter is
now fully um they've gone only fans
adults which is interesting because I
wouldn't expect that a lot of people
would want to see them naked but again I
I don't know because it seems like
they're doing very well there but you
could see their dicks out pretty much I
think I don't know there was a bunch of
I think people thirst for the island
boys like a twin fantasy I don't know
you saw some [__]
only fans because I haven't said but
they're doing new stuff yeah so what I
was going to say is they've been doing
incestors yeah
so in there isn't it I think what
they're I think they're incest baiting
and I'll show you someone's got to do
something so because there was something
where they're like they were making fun
of them a lot about them being like
ancestral and they're like no that's
nasty bro what the [__] and now that
they're on only fans
look at this they started baiting the
incest incest
how crazy is this I was utterly
speechless speechless guys we actually
kissed oh my God
holding him what's your argument dude
why is he kissing him lots of questions
I asked what is happening here they're
touching tongues
love ya no homo there's ones on Twitter
where like he acts like he's revan's
brother's [__] yeah
but I guess it's working for them uh why
is this happening
I don't know if this blew my God damn
mind also I'm still just so confused by
them like just the whole thing like
are they are they like super rich I
think they're making a lot from only
fans no but like did they are their
parents super rich I guess is the better
no I think at first they made some
dollars on Cameo and then they leverage
that into incest uh only fans
okay but this actually
I mean this is this is utterly shocking
I I was I was mind blown
really
I can almost feel his lips
I'm not ready yet
dude
no the and someone said I thought they
must for sure not be Blood Brothers no
they are twins they're fraternal twins
they are that's the blood of God that's
right okay so there they are if you're
wondering what happened up to the island
boys
they are doing incest babies I'm an
island boy trying to kiss my own brother
I'm touching my dick to my brother's
dick
a tongue to a tongue yeah
take it off the screen it's gross stop
it
I'm an incest boy alex there looks okay
the real names are Alex and Frankie
Alex and Frankie wait it's not Island
Boy it was not Alex and Frankie oh they
are twins you guys they're fraternal
twins for leaving an ALICE Alex
uh their siblings by chance Lovers by
choice
the twins their father died when they're
young and they were raised by a single
mother Twins were often in trouble with
the law and commit crimes blah blah blah
mother kicked him out at 18.
one of them has a daughter of course
they do of course he does
obviously it sucks
surprised you don't have more kids
well they still hopefully the daughter's
gonna be well provided for
cheers my dude so wait there's another
set of twins who are apparently doing
incest Javier
Javier
I gotta see this let me take it off
doesn't say Javier said
Javier
twins
that's your argument
there's no argument you know especially
same set it's not hobby people are
saying it's the the UVU Java guy you
remember that vine this guy I mean here
people I see people I don't recognize
wait is this a woman it's a woman though
no
[Music]
person but there are a few articles
about doing gay porn with his brother
that must be illegal I think it's
actually no it's illegal in all 50
states it is I was researching it
because I was during Father's Day
talking to my family about the island
boys incest porn and then I started
being like is this illegal and what
you'll find interesting is in a lot of
countries it is still legal and even in
countries like Ireland they specifically
even carve out they say same-sex incest
relationships are legal well opposite
sex incest is illegal wow in Ireland it
seems
like the opposite would be the more
harmful
no people no the ones where they can
have a baby is illegal oh okay oh that's
what I was okay yeah I understand right
legal I find that interesting that they
carved that out though so the island boy
you know what Ireland's an island I can
move right out there yo I love that good
logic
yeah Ireland legal same-sex couple
illegal opposite sex couples it's not
odd so they make that distinction
so apparently there's no federal law
against incest but each of the 50 states
has a law so I'm not really sure the
history of enforcing incest law in
America
but uh hopefully there's not too big of
a need there
what's your argument though at the end
of the day
what's your argument wait it looks like
there's somewhere in the United States
where it's legal
every 50 state it's illegal I'm seeing
Rhode Island this chart is showing Rhode
Island and
is that what state is that I'm pretty
sure I'm Jersey
here it says sexual agency family
members who are not spouses formerly
known as incest is illegal across the
U.S uh insist laws
in the United States oh boy here we go
this is what I went down this Rabbit
Hole yesterday and it's like wow I spent
a long time in this and you're just like
wow I spent a long time learning about
incest
so Americans let's see uh
prohibited acts yeah here it's a however
individual statutes uh very widely Rhode
Island has repealed its criminal incest
debt so there was somebody Rhode Island
and New Jersey it is New Jersey more
Island Boys hold on there's somebody in
New Jersey and Rhode Island who took a
law before the state congress
and they says we need to make incest
legal I need to watch that movie uh yeah
Rhode Island's a little bit of a wild
state from what I understand
um also uh island in the name
perhaps they should move there
so in Hawaii not actually an island they
have so many options well the
punishment's pretty crazy for some of
these in Georgia
incest is punishable well I guess that
makes sense because usually it's our
word but that's already a crime 10 to 30
years for that in Georgia
father and child are stepchild oh step
child don't tell Woody Allen
stepchild that people a lot of people
get in trouble for that in Hollywood
father and stepchild mother and child or
stepchild brother sister or the whole
blood or half blood so you can't even
[__] your half sister
where's the justice
what's the argument
grandparent and grandchild that's just
[__] insane I even like that they
even said that Aunt cheers my dude oh
you can't even [__] your uncle or Aunt
come on
come on give me something
life in Idaho you can get life in prison
damn
person within degrees of Constantine
constantinity which makes marriage
incestuous and void life in prison in
Idaho
that's pretty wild
there it is incest boys so in in 1989
Rhode Island
repealed its criminal incest law in 1989
I gotta know the history who put that
forward he's [__] is somebody he
shouldn't be
I wanted names
how do you how do you bring how did the
congress even vote to pass that hold it
I want
oh wait someone actually made a good
point about Woody Allen it wasn't even
his stepdaughter it was his adopted
daughter so this is just a straight up
daughter
situation
repealed all of its criminal incest laws
leaving the Civil marriage prohibitions
intact
to get married
they're in Rhode Island but there's no
criminal so are they in Rhode Island or
New Jersey
did they moved to an insist incest Haven
I believe they're still in Florida but I
can look
dude
thank God there's New Jersey the last
place where Freedom still exists in
America
we have a beautiful Community down here
in New Jersey where freedom is freedom
and you can [__] whoever you want
including your own damn brother
Freedom means having sex with my mom
Freedom means having sex with my dad
Freedom means having sex with my dog
oh that's still legal walk that one back
and just to be clear having sex with
animals is a different thing
[Music]
thank you
uh hey I don't know I don't want to give
Sam a graphic flashbacks but this made
me think of her from the live the last
lives it was Sam right the guy yeah
so I guess we should mute it I sent this
to her as soon as I saw it somebody
threw a phone like right like why would
they do that so that she could take a
photo with it is that the idea I guess
we were trying to figure that out at the
live show someone threw a phone at Sam
and it hit her in the exact same place
and we were trying to figure out what
they wanted like if they wanted Sam to
take a photo on it which by the way if
you were the person that was at the show
who did that and you're watching right
now like I hope you're forever
embarrassed about doing it like what the
[__] why did what were you thinking I
would I was in shock I looked overhead
Sam I go did I just witness dude did
they just throw that at you it just
chucked your phone I wish I saw somebody
on the stage you saw the person who did
it unbelievable yeah I saw the person oh
man I was I wish mid-boxing training I
was ready to go I was like like why did
you that was that I don't think they
meant to hurt her but no genuinely don't
understand what your thought process was
because you want your phone yeah it's
not like an empty bottle it's your phone
it has to be that they want her to film
I I hope you're watching and cringing
out of your skin right now
okay wait this is interesting though her
hand looks like she's looking to catch
something oh is she just singing or is
she like yo throw me your phone I mean
it's hard to tell it seemed like she was
just doing Jazz fingers yeah
foreign
coming
wow wow dude
that was bad so yeah so please on Friday
no throwing phones at the stage thank
you I will kick you out if you throw
phones on the stage yeah
especially if you guys see anyone like
that let me know
so we can at least humiliate them it's
just weird yeah
well shout out Sam
um POV your daughter's boyfriend won't
trigger warning this is interesting
what in God's [__] name is this [__]
oh there's no audio
we have to meet audio okay so let me uh
let me narrate this for you guys hey
sweetheart hide's arm why are you hiding
your arm uh nothing it's nothing show me
sees bruises who did that to you I fell
who did that to you your boyfriend
he didn't mean to wait but he's not the
boyfriend he's the dad where does he
live where does he live under the State
Bridge what what your boyfriend lives
under the bridge okay so what we have
more issues going on there's more issues
at play than the bruise on your arm
actually since we bring this one up
um
there is
another Instagram account that I've been
following that is really entertaining
uh is it this guy Timon Creek this is
the guy yeah
no I
yeah actually maybe potentially we have
a few Alphas in the dock this is uh
let's see who's this one this is the guy
we talked about yeah this I I can't get
enough I keep getting his videos
specifically on Instagram I get his
videos all the time on my Discover page
yeah
and to be honest he's kind of warming on
me in a weird way
because like German in general because
like
wait which one is this here I'll show
you he's the guy like hey bro we're
gonna go out oh yeah he's less
he's less horrible than most of them
it's just goofy listen if my lady is an
overthinker then I'm gonna be an
overexplainer I have no issue putting a
mind at ease the goal is to build trust
not destroy it
he's kind of like making being a like
pathetic simp like cool and I like that
that's better not even pathetic you know
yeah that just seemed like that's
generally good advice yes but all of his
videos are like step on my throat and
call me a [__] mom or I don't know he's
just
but it's kind of cool because he's
jacked and he's out here telling good I
think good things he's kind of corny
I don't like the element of it of the
the grind Set uh you know oh he's very
religious too he's very religious and
he's very like oh you want to go enjoy
your Youth and have fun and create
memories I'm gonna be becoming rich in
my bedroom alone yeah that aspect of it
I'm not a fan of but uh but I don't know
that that seemed wholesome I'd rather
him act like that than like say girls
are so stupid yeah no he's definitely
not the worst like compared to you know
what you else you hear out there for
advice for men I think this guy's kind
of getting a dub yeah I feel yeah I have
no idea of putting a mind I just find it
funny when you say stuff like we don't
do that around here who's we he always
says we not all the time he's creating a
community of like he's World building
are you kidding me right now the
editorial way is the proverbial way okay
here let's see
David was depressed Jacob was a cheater
Moses was anxious Noah got drunk
God can change your life okay hold on
those are not equal
excuse me
let's be real about this one you got to
take a step back here Timon David was
depressed not his fault Jacob was a
cheater Jacob is a [__] cheater he
did that Moses was anxious Moses being
anxious not his fault as a condition
Noah got drunk Noah got drunk God can
change liquids
come on let's have some little more
nuanced life in a moment
he qualifies the unqualified
I don't know what that means
I don't know what that means gotta join
the we to find out man you're gonna join
his Circle five things to remember every
day
yes five things that I want you to
remember every day
don't chase anyone don't beg anyone to
stay know your worth save space for
people who matter and love yourself yes
slay
[Applause]
he's so sensitive literally
like and these get a lot of views so you
have to think like hmm if he's actually
influencing people this is kind of a dub
you know
love yourself brother that's what the
[__] I'm talking about
although can you imagine being a
relationship with him I just get I just
can't imagine it'd be that good love
yeah
his production quality is so good too
it's impressive I don't think there's a
team behind him or what but I mean it's
always on a tripod I think that's just
him but tripod depth of field good audio
good lighting yeah I agree also he's in
front of green screen also his road is
like dripped out like a necklace sorry
yeah
this one this one's good
he goes this quote Hit me hard I just
heard the hardest hitting quotes ever
ever it says if your absence doesn't
bother them your presence never means
anything to them
yeah and then a lot of them is kind of
this this pseudo like uh
women brick I don't know how to describe
it it's a lot of this stuff where it's
like
just leave her bro it's almost like you
hear like the just leave them it's kind
of like him just leave her bro
I'm gonna keep going
that was the hardest hitting quote ever
he said yes
walking away has nothing to do with
weakness that's a great take
sometimes walking away has nothing to do
with weakness yes and everything to do
with strength yes we walk away not
because we want others to realize our
worth and value
but because we finally realize our own
time it out to where by the
is his
camera or do we think he doesn't think
about that he definitely does like 100 I
think so as well I think he does it a
few times until he does it when he gets
there at the Finish Line 100 walking
away has nothing to do with weakness
and everything to do with yeah that's
like straight up good advice for young
men
you know cheers my dude if we date
promise me oh oh there's Rules of
Engagement and he's in the dark can we
date I need you to promise me that if
you ever lose interest in me
you'll respect me enough to tell me true
don't keep me in your life to gain
confidence and energy from my loyalty
and affection Right Rob let me go so I
can invest my time and energy into
someone who will value and respect me
right
it's very it's very like nice guy like
the bad nice guy but it's not that bad
it's like good advice mixed with nice
guy energy it's really weird to explain
it's hard to explain this guy I think of
like protector maybe you know
Alpha protector yeah
like a like a sexy young Terminator dude
look at these shots man
it's so fun on games until I'm
unreachable because listen I'm sorry for
your loss wait what but I'm not
available no more because I got to
protect my energy
as a matter of fact
I'll go ghost before I let myself be
taken advantage of so he's like yo my
girls it's so fun again just had a I'm
sorry for your loss like somebody died
but he's like uh
listen I know your mom died
girly I'm the loss
my dude okay interesting stuff I'm just
got an interesting outlook on life can't
I'm captivated I can't look away from
his videos every time it is wild I sent
one of his videos and my whole feed is
that now yeah
yeah
because he gets a lot of Engagement yeah
and part of the mystery is just like
who's watching this
it's time to go
go do the thing that God has called you
to do do it scared
do it unsure
do it even if no one understands
but please for the sake of a generation
crying out for hope
go do the thing that God has called you
to do that's straight up like you could
literally play that at Isis recruitment
take this bomb do what God told you to
do
uh brother we love it though don't we
folks an experienced its gentle caress
damn Zack
I'm kind of glad I'm difficult to deal
with and understand to be honest
because at least I know when someone
sticks around
they truly want to right
it's a if you can't handle me at my
worst you don't deserve me at my best
for men
I love that that's special and beautiful
so shout out to Timon Creek
cheers my dude
cheers my dude Timon
um let's talk let's get into uh the
Pearly thing now we've we've done enough
at the top of the show no let me hear
say let's get into the just pearly
things
I love it I am I you know
I have mixed feelings on Pearl after
everything has gone down really in the
sense that
her existence is so sad
there's so much self-loathing there
the internet the interplay of just like
self-loathing and
the clear and present and constant
rejection she's getting by the men
around who have no interest in her
and like she rates herself a five
she can't be happy
no
how can you be happy bro
um
I know it's hard to answer well I do
know what makes her happy it's singing
it's singing that makes her happy
now what we did is how did we find these
songs can we get a background on this so
initially someone posted uh Drake's song
on the subreddit that she sung and said
it was on her LinkedIn and so we took a
look and we found that there were some
others yeah so what we did is we
downloaded them all quickly without a
feeling she was going to erase it when
she found out this was public
and then we ran it through the the uh AI
to remove the background music so this
is all good baby says you guys are
awesome thank you for your patience as I
get to all your song requests
oh [__] she was taking requests requests
here we go
um
you should call me on my work phone yes
and you need a printer printer
all day when you need a printer printer
yeah these songs are all tailored to
whatever business she was working in at
the time yeah she's writing this for
businesses
whatever business she was in it yeah all
the songs are her own lyrics like a spin
on yeah yeah no I know it's a lyric
they're all printer related they're all
Pearl Originals
she's got one in there called copiers
ain't easy so uh okay how is she not a
character from The Office she's making
songs about printers and papers we found
our Angela
literally I know when that work phone
ring yes
that you need to print things
the cannon you
got paper jam [__] right now she goes
I've been in the professional workspace
and I've never been looked over before
I haven't I have a lifetime experience I
have never had trouble getting the same
phase man
I have a lot of experience in Corporate
America this is the experience
yeah I made parody songs on LinkedIn
yep
kaga sorry jamming lesson printing more
Easy Feeling get you on the Dance Floor
get rid of that rap you've never seen
before
um you should call me on my work phone
yo that was fire wow
and I do find it interesting uh that she
was bringing up Drake a few times about
him being like the ultimate male with
but high body count that women want yeah
I think she has a thing for Drake yeah
many women do
do they really Drake is so goofy like
what do you mean he's like the biggest
artist I know that Drake's goofy but
like in terms of like hot dudes who
people want to [__] I think he's goofy I
think a lot of people think he's goofy
but yeah I mean right yeah back me up
y'all it's a weird split people people
thirst over Drake big time yeah
definitely yeah I don't know
this this guy
this guy that guy this one here and that
guy call me on my work phone he's the co
he's the corniest man alive I like his
music I like his music's so good
piranha printer call me when you need a
printer call me on my work phone
need a printer
so that's just one we have more yeah
here we go oh no I'm here saying
boom boom boom yeah we had this Epiphany
on Friday that she is the boom boom
whale girl
10 years later
fantastic
okay so here's Old Town Road
um
and there was a phone number at the end
for the business which we cut out
but so businesses were paying her for
this that doesn't make any sense to me
so I guess
um I'm reading people requested uh
ringtones for their companies during
covid
people put this as their voice no I
don't think so no but she offered it she
was getting trolled right like there's
zero shot anybody used that I agree
I'm so sorry she goes uh let's see
decided to have some fun on this fine
Sunday if you got this voicemail what
would you do so maybe she's trying to
solicit her talents
so here it is Old Time Road by Pearl
Yemen name I love that she sings with
the two-digit fingers I'll help you save
till I can no more my name is Pearl from
Konica I'll help you save till I can no
more we got the printers in the back
skin yeah she I love that she's on the
printer stuff this one kind of hits
so she's a printer sales person yeah
and so she worked her way to the top man
the men couldn't keep up with her
I made 25 cents more per hour than my
milk also isn't this kind of demonic to
be singing a little not sex song yes
also he's black I don't know if she got
that memo oh no so true yeah black and
gay
yeah it's a problem
um
although this explains everything in the
sense that I don't think she's like
socially her social awareness is
something yeah I mean she's sheltered
raised by nannies went to private
Catholic School
yeah I mean those people generally are
pretty weird do you think if our friend
saw this it would ruin her life
[Music]
it doesn't matter what it could come out
that she's had sex with a hundred dudes
this would damage her more this is going
to damage her more
when you have 10 kids this is what
happens to the kids man
right because they have like 10 kids
this is what happens you know you don't
give them any attention you don't make
them feel special and then they end up
covering Old Town Road on LinkedIn to
sell printers
I mean
they don't have as many kids it's so
crazy dude
we do
software Solutions someone says this is
fair this feels kind of mean somebody
said in a sense
I get that but also we have to consider
the fact that
she's a horrible person right like right
yeah so we can definitely worth
considering we're good to proceed I feel
in consideration of everything she said
and who she is I believe that we have
every right to if you say slavery is
embellished we can make fun of your
character that's worse that's that's a
fair trade in my opinion that's worse
what she said yeah right right that's
worse yes that feels a little mean to me
but I do I think it's worth unpacking
that though you know yeah she's being
transphobic on Twitter right now too if
that happens oh great Consciousness
that's a little mean yeah let's watch
that Drake cover
she's freaking out right now though
there has not all we do
you see him Solutions
of how Konica Minolta can help you save
money
Pearl Davis
okay so she's really trying to find
something that works for her
professionally and I think this kind of
explains how she fell into this grip she
really trying to find her way trying to
find a make a living
in a
unorthodox way right she trying to I
don't understand why why doesn't she
just get married and stay home pump out
kids about a good man bring home the
bread you know what I'm saying a hundred
percent
that is pretty odd
well she already has money she wants
attention and this looks like her first
shot at it and then we got into the
grift yeah yeah my name is Pearl from
Kanika
no more meter reads no more hidden fees
just me with me and you will see this is
kind of gorgeous that's not only do
software solutions that do
there has not only do
ECM solutions they do
that rendition of how cool
yo sell me a printer sign me up no
I want the printer I want the scanner
and I want the software Solutions
here's another one Truth Hurts by lizzo
okay I'm noticing a trend here these are
all black artists
very true very true fake Lil Nas and now
lizzo
she hates lizzo but she's covering
lizzo's song interesting a little noise
right wait yeah we saw it not not a
tweets she has like 30 videos about
lizzo on her uh Tick Tock and on her
YouTube fan Behavior but then she she's
a fan of Rizzo huh
wow
she mad that uh here let's let's open
this uh this is hot off the press from
Pearl's Twitter I am transgender and
transphobic at the same time daddy
issues I guess hold on what did you just
say
because that's not impossible did I mean
look at there's look at the uh Blair
white right
I don't get the joke
I don't know but I don't know what this
is about she's going on this whole thing
now that she's um transitioning and her
new pronouns are her majesty or your
majesty awesome never heard that joke
she did the one joke dude
my pronouns are what are check out this
pronoun joke I just thought of
[Music]
my pronoun is big dick
thank you
uh the reason people like pearly things
and I are against feminism oh I gotta
look into her is because we see that it
has ruined Society okay oh oh you saw
that actually is a decent point
okay that's interesting there's a
growing number of women who see it my
new YouTube series will cover the
arguments and details starting tomorrow
it's time to end this failed experiment
okay Rachel okay hmm yeah her name is
Rach for patriarchy uh let's see what do
we got here we got the Orthodox cross uh
patriarchy
who knows rage for patriarchy that's
awesome cool yeah she's crushing it uh
three 800 views on this one Rachel calls
for an end to abortion thank you Rachel
for finally saying that
we love you Rach
all right so here is lizzo
Kanika is gray using R1 right
we just took a DNA test turns out we're
a hundred percent the best even when
we're going crazy because we do see
problems that's a human in US bling
bling then we solve them that's a
Salesman in US Coulda had one right now
hold on she loves lizzo
she's she loves the song that's bad
you got your behavior
find out what you did about lizzo I want
to compare that helped you with your
billing just the little building's too
complex and it's a holding you back and
that's the sound of you calling me back
yo cause gray using R1 right click rates
man why they gotta variate no hidden
fees they can do one right no meter read
stick and do one right find out of your
current contract new copies are attached
truth or it's kind of cause guy you're
back
you know God damn you know
I gotta say if I called a business and
this was their answering machine I would
be intrigued well you think it's
effective yeah I would be intrigued
uh everybody was suggesting alternate uh
pronouns for her in the chat and this
one really got me Baron suggested her
pronouns are copy slash her copier
pretty good that is good pretty good
printer scanner
software Solutions my pronoun is
software Solutions
uh here she's tweeting out lizzo I would
actually have a very real conversation
on why what you promote doesn't the more
harm than good I used to love her music
okay Fallen fan
actually until I realized the words I
was singing the hell
until I realized that I left that video
on LinkedIn
that that's what that is
so this is June 1st though
no I know well she knows I should put
that up somewhere for sure right she has
to acknowledge it
that's very interesting that she's
adding lizzo I mean I'm surprised Liza
didn't uh respond yeah weird
let's see
lizzo let me help you get healthy I've
struggled with weight too let's fix the
problem well this is actually she really
just wants to be her friend yeah for
sure
this is why everyone bullies lizzo the
issue is like we have open
Adriana saw
a song oh I'm the victim they're coming
at me for just existing why is she deep
fried pictures on these they do this
I've noticed her and some other people
they just crank the contrast all the way
up I don't know why I don't know why
they do what
it looks crazy like what
hold on let me start this video over
with the lizzo song Monica has gray
using R1 right
the issue is like we have openness
that's how she started and she's gonna
play victim and say that
they're coming at me for just existence
[Music]
dude [__] Pearl's great she has been
like such a great source of content
if you search for um
oh these are all lizzo videos the hell
lizzo hates men okay I'll buy it let's
talk about how listen oh there's music
[__]
just turns out I 100 hate men
[Music]
leave
look at this [__] leave the whales with
pearl
140 000 views
oh there's a whole lot I do not forget
to subscribe subscribe to channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
nightmare right there top comment I
approach two heavyset ladies at the bar
after hearing them talk about are you
ladies from Scotland one of them uh
replied it's whales you jerk so I said
sorry about that are you are you Wales
from Scotland [__] owned owned Jesus
owned didn't happen that is the thing
that has happened the least that's never
happened in your life I've watched quite
a few of these videos now and it's quite
shocking how consistently women refuse
to accept responsibility and make
outrageous excuses for poor decisions
God help us
so brave
there's more I mean each one spawns a
new conversation
so that's lizzo
um up next
we've got the copiers ain't easy now I
don't know if this was I I assume it was
an existing song I I couldn't recognize
what it was but um let's just call it
copiers uh Ain't Easy
this is she's still going on about trans
stuff I went to college and I did well I
played three different sports I did mock
trials I graduated two different degrees
but I still had a trans person down the
hall for me in my dorm
huh I don't recommend we send young
women to college it's an indoctrination
Camp what that's an outrageous wait wait
wait what it's almost like she's telling
us that she's grifting you guys know
Bobby boucher's mom and Waterboy how she
said the devil everything's the devil
That's The Vibes I'm getting from her
college is the devil can you help me
unpack this she says I went to college I
did great I did great but I still had a
trans person down the hall for me and
the door all of it isn't worth it I
still had it and then I had a hard time
that's the sentiment what is the button
doing what what's that like I did so
well in school but I shouldn't have gone
because there was a trans person down
the hall and they it's contagious they
you might if you send your kid to
college they might catch the tram but
that's there's no relation between the
first part so right because the trans
person
she's getting ahead of the hypocrisy
accusations of telling people oh you
shouldn't send your kids to college
their indoctrination camps and people
would rightfully be like you're once
you're seeing all that in this yeah no
shot she believes I speak right-wing
grifter I'm fluent
she says I went to college I did well I
played Sports I got degrees but despite
mentions the sports thing uh
I think she's lying about the sports by
the way
I
maybe I don't know who cares I mean she
probably was in sports I I was she
good
she says despite all my successes in the
school I still had a trans person down
the hall for me in the dorm I don't
recommend we send young women to college
isn't it okay so she's saying
just having a trans person down the hall
in a dorm which are quite large
you know in my dorm there was quite a
lot there was like five floors and quite
a lot of people on each floor yeah so
this person wasn't even close to her
yeah it's like it's like typhoid or like
some other
super contagious disease so she had this
fantastic experience at school I did
great I played Sports I did mock trials
I did two degrees
but I cannot I cannot recommend other
women no I ban all other women from
getting this experience I had because
there's a chance they might meet a trans
person
very interesting and they might turn
trans like I didn't ah that took me a
while to figure that one out
I had to unravel that
copiers Ain't Easy
see
happier bye
[Music]
oh my gosh
sales reps rather give you the cheap
than sell you the best
low toner paper jams in the resolution
each day begins a new issue if you don't
understand it and it don't break Zoom
you're probably just throw it away
cheers
please jumped away it's a company grow
up to buy Xerox
they like smile at the end of the line
or slow service
no homo
[Music]
she should make like a Christmas album
about Oliver Printing and Xerox songs
yes printing printing scanners and
software Solutions with pearl happy
Merry Christmas
you said she played volleyball right
volleyball and basketball
they'll always break and they'll never
work call me again
yeah you love
wow
call me a Copier you love boom boom boom
now let me hear you say well
oh yeah so this is the girl who kind of
I think inspired her ultimately and she
looks just like her man uh we we
shouldn't uh oh it gets clean yeah yeah
we removed the audio and it still gets
claimed yeah
because she she hits it too hard the
boom boom booms oh no let me hear her
say well
that
does it gets Progressive you can still
hear the original uh wayos no um
so there it is uh Pearl Davis also known
as Sammy Davis pearly
Sammy Davis pearly
also known as
Davis Jefferson Pearl
thank you Davis Jefferson being the uh
president of the Confederacy thank you
right did I say his name right I think
it's Jefferson Davis yeah Jefferson
Davis yeah yeah Jefferson Davis Pearl
that's a good one thank you I thought it
was not bad I mean no I actually thought
it was pretty good yeah Pearl Jefferson
better than the Sammy Davis yeah Pearl
Jefferson Davis and the Rat Pack and the
Rat Pack
Sammy Davis Jr you don't like that I'm
confused on that one well it's just
because Davis was in there but it's like
Sammy
Sammy Sammy David Davis no his name is
Davis
that's great Sammy Davis pearly Davis Jr
I'm so I'm sorry that's good they sing
too they both sing they both sing and
they're both great
all right well there it is
just pearly things
no more no more songs that's it I wish
there's such a short-lived career yeah
you were robbed
there's four of them
they're all iconic just like uh my band
The jokes we have four songs then we
disappeared
wow
you know I miss Pearl's old stuff
before she sold out yeah yeah the first
couple albums were great but she went
followed her on tour yeah
okay I want to talk about the RFK stuff
now actually I'm gonna go pee real fast
I genuinely genuinely want to debate RFK
I feel like this has become our
specialty I have it is
we're uh we're working on reaching out
so um like
I think our specialty is
debating people who
you so usually you can't debate people
like
who are transphobic or uh uh anti-vaxx
or flat earthers like we've talked about
this because they have all these made up
talking points that are like impossible
to address
and they just railroad through you but I
feel that
I feel that that's our specialty where
we put up
we put up the road sign on the railroad
track I feel this we say ah
this train is slowing down
tell me what the [__] does that mean
oh our uh Robert Kennedy Jr who is
the nephew
nephew of JFK son of RFK yeah RFK
and so um he's a real [__] weirdo
but I'm gonna go through I'm gonna go
pee and then we'll talk about it okay
okay sounds good sounds good let me uh
get back to the super chats because
there's
[__] ton today
uh Connor don't have five bucks and said
Happy Father's Day to Ethan Ethan Connor
says Happy Father's Day
um to Alpha king daddy role model Ethan
Klein and all the stand-up dads out
there Ethan is looking Dopey
wow I'm sorry I didn't hear that it's
Friday evening that's from last week
Ethan don't eat that pizza
[Music]
go for it no we got a life I can hear it
if it's in the fridge it's fine
all weekend
I I don't know he has no people I
thought you were eating trash Pizza
there were a lot of boxes on the floor
yeah exactly all right uh Turk donated
uh 550 Canadian Buckaroo news
that's what I'm going for Ethan needs
more credit for his weight loss I've
been trying to gain what I've been
trying to gain weight for 14 months now
and I've only gained five pounds
love you successful skinny King
we go in the opposite direction
uh congrats on your five pounds gained
uh Max donated 10 bucks and said can I
get a pride minute I'm trans and had Top
surgery this last Friday I've been
recovering catching up on the lives well
congratulations Max and uh
is it really Pride man if Ethan's not
here can we do that are we like
authorized to do that without him about
30 seconds can we do 30 seconds half a
minute
get the music going
throw up Max Max
um
throw up the pride flag overlay
and you know we'll just kind of set the
mood here
um
and get it right I'm not gonna do like
the southern preacher condemning gay
people at the end of this that Ethan
likes to do but
but we will
we will create a vibe in Grid
donated 100 uh Nokia's phones
no n okay is that
uh Norwegian Norwegian yeah yeah okay
and Nokia is from Norway is it not
um I have no idea I think it's finished
I'm not sure I think Nokia is from
Finland oh Finland okay anyways uh
Ingrid says I swear I turned 21 today
please play the sound by Zach Attack go
ahead just need documentation it just
I'll excuse it
they're Norwegian and every single one
says they're 21.
some 21 year olds you think they're on
this town go [__] strategy
21. [__] you there it is Anna donated
two bucks and said traveling from
Minnesota for the live show oh wow all
the way from Minnesota
wow this is probably a bad time to
announce where our next show is next
month
just kidding
um I was like what Jackie B donate two
bucks and said it's my birthday happy
birthday happy birthday Leonora said I
have an iPhone from Italy and mine never
crashed
yeah it just it's really inconsistent I
don't I don't know Los Angeles they've
never crashed some people say they crash
10 times a day I don't know you guys do
a five minute without me
I
specifically said I don't know if it's
right to do it without Ethan so let's
just play the music and put up the flag
and we'll just kind of have the vibe and
let you make the ultimate call thank you
because it's your It's Your Thing uh so
Jose donate five bucks and he didn't
send a message King love you Jose love
you
chance five bucks uh how many people on
the guest list for the live show you
know it's getting up there but it has
not reached 80 uh or even not even close
not even that close
uh oh Jose try it again and got the
message through this time
um bought a ticket for the live show but
won't be able to fly there
oh what's the best way to give another
fupa Trooper can enjoy I believe so it's
through AXS I think you can refund it
and it you put it back into the pool or
I think there's a second Market you'll
you can sell it to someone else right
yeah or they have some sort of uh
who's the Ethan Klein that just popped
up there I have
um uh do a little bit
go go to the login to AXS and take a
look I think that there is a way to
release the ticket and somebody can
potentially pick it up there's lots of
people that are waiting list is very
long so
um sure you'll be able to sell it sorry
you can't make it man sorry about that
and Adam donated uh ten dollars with no
message and then donated a few minutes
later again
with another ten dollars and remembered
hello it's my girlfriends
sorry if I'm saying it wrong malikus
uh it's their 21st birthday today and I
mean the world to her you guys give her
a shout out she already sent everything
the proof in Discord 21
hold on we got to confirm it all right
hold on let me look what was that uh
what's that kid's name from [__] yeah
what does that make love single one says
we're 21.
21 year olds you think they're on this
town oh here's the video of Sam getting
hit by the phone
whoa I haven't seen this yeah I didn't
know it was on video I was
wait I haven't seen this
you go to the beginning
oh [__]
um
so
whoa what the [__] was that wait wait
what happened did you get his phone wait
I did see it oh there you got it this is
so confusing so wait
Sam was ready
like hands and then it whacked her in
the eyebrow oh I don't think she was
ready I think she just saw it flying
through the air and reacted
I oh my God man whose phone is that oh
God oh God wait why are you throwing
your phone up are you you're like let me
see it you had a whole interaction
wow I don't remember dude
I don't remember
so I did see them
um well
first of all let's not throw our phones
it was a little less malicious than I
than Bebe rexha then I thought it may
have been
still insane thing to do
you know and you heard Sam you demon
what the [__] was that
how'd you get his phone
wait what how'd you get it home
I looked at exactly should we go jump in
the [__] crowd whose phone is that
damn I look massive bro
that was a big time for me huh big boy
real big boy hours holy [__] look at all
that that was actually already on the
decline though was it yeah this is past
the peak peek was like because this was
the end of 2022 last year it was like
summer of last year I feel like this
when you were maxing out
that shirt fits me like a Mumu dress
[Applause]
a little bit if I may simp I would just
say that night I was so impressed uh how
well you performed because you were so
sick like I don't know if you're ready
I love you for that
um I cannot find the proof that was
supposedly sent about the 21st birthday
from malachas but just just play it back
[__] you
all right
everybody calm down all right
calm down
all right is there more shoot can we get
onto the
uh there's more but we can we can move
on we've been doing it thank you Luke
for the 50. what a legendary I will save
my spot and try and get back to it later
do this there's so many today uh maybe
at the end we can just yeah over a bunch
of really good at the same time it's
like as much as I I want to recognize
your guys's generosity and your messages
the show would just become that at the
same time I do have to do a show that's
watchable for the majority of people
here I mean
so but thank you guys okay so RFK
is um
also known as roof
oh I think we need to we need to we
disavow this idiot
um oh
Ian can summon them overlay yeah
because he's doing covid [__]
so CDs
so here's a whole cheers my dude
highlight from it
yeah go ahead I'll set it up
so yeah the nephew of JFK
the conversation was just a slew of
unchecked vaccine misinfo
conspiracy mongering 5G technology BS
and of course Rogan praising ivermectom
Y how
I don't know how he's still on that I
thought I genuinely thought he had
dropped it at this point because I
haven't heard about Ivermectin in a
while but I guess he's still stuck into
his gun that was one of the dumbest
things that came out of the whole
pandemic it really was people were
taking ivermectum
an anti-worming drug what was like
initial like there was like
at the very beginning some sense from
some doctors like oh maybe this could
help but it was like in the panic mode
time when everybody was trying to find
anything to communitigate this disease
that was just ripping through the
population
um but pretty quickly people came to
realize that it wasn't really effective
and since then there's been extensive
studies that have confirmed that it
doesn't help with kovid so like how are
you still on this at this point I think
I think it even showed like a worse
outcome if that was I thought it was
just like it just doesn't do anything
but the thing is like this is a
conclusion made by scientists so they
like him this scientific conclusion
about ivermectom or it wasn't a
scientific collusion but it was it's not
a theory
but then when it comes to all the other
science we don't like it
here is uh let's see uh Robert F Kennedy
Jr and Joe Rogan uh talking about old
school this is old school anti-back [__]
we got the thing up Ian
and well the the way that this story
goes is [__] crazy and Elon Musk is
such a piece of sh like he is the worst
so bear with us because this story is
pretty great all the way throughout when
I had heard of you in the past before I
had read your book no sorry what is art
what is his qualifications is he even a
lawyer servant huh is he even a public
servant
uh I don't think so I don't think he's
ever run for office before like I I know
that they're a family of generally
pretty smart people
but uh why is he talking about all this
[__] he has no expertise so the thing is
is that he has been an anti a pretty
prominent person in the anti-vaxx world
for
um
for a long while now he was pretty early
from what I understand on the whole
vaccines cause autism train
um but he has in recent years kind of
backed off of that or just you know
equivocated on it
um and I think that's why this Rogan
interview is
uh Making Waves because I guess he felt
like he was in good company with Rogan
and just let it rip with [__] with it
all so he's a presidential hopeful so
he's trying to primary uh uh Joseph
Robinette uh Biden
which is weird because he's running as a
Democrat but the only people that like
him are conservatives it's not that
weird it's just a spoiler candidate
thing it happens in a lot of
presidential races okay so here are two
Geniuses talking about vaccines when I
had heard of you in the past before I
had read your book and before I'd met
you I had no information on you oh he
also thinks uh HIV doesn't cause AIDS by
the way
well so that's interesting a conclusion
to make as someone who has no experience
in science
right because that seems like a high
level scientific conclusion that's a
good conclusion to make as someone who
works in podcasts true well I'm saying
I'm saying yeah no you talking about the
right choice yeah talk to the people
that have dedicated their lives to the
science
I don't know [__] about nothing this
narrative was you were anti-vaxx and you
were you believed in pseudoscience and
you were kind of loony
yes I didn't look into it at all I just
took it at face value because that's
what everybody had said and in my mind
vaccines have been one of the most
important medical advancements in human
history to save countless lives
protected children and I thought very
strongly that they were important
I didn't have any information on that
either don't you [__] walk that back
please this was also just a narrative
adopted from
cursory reading of news articles dude
you know not really getting into the
subject at all
then the pandemic happens
and I had quite a few very reasonable
liberal people rational people people
that I I trusted their mind recommend
the real Anthony fauci your book and I'm
like Robert Kennedy wrote a book about
the I thought Anthony fauci like what is
this gonna oh my God he wrote a book
about
the real Anthony arrest fauci his
pronouns are arrest fouchy
holy [__] man this is my initial
reaction you've got this what I perceive
to be a kind of fringy thinking you know
almost conspiracy theorist type person
that's not based in fact what their
argument was and he had written a book
on Anthony fauci
so I I had
seen numerous interviews with you and
you know
uh you seemed very reasonable and very
rational
and therefore
therefore uh quick synopsis on that book
uh the book accuses uh Public Health
leader Anthony fauci of 30 years of
abuse of power during uh the HIV
epidemic and the covid-19 pandemic
include statements by Tucker Carlson uh
Naomi wolf Oliver Stone and Alan
dershowitz uh just uh Alan dershowitz
bestie
I love that he's running as a Democrat
forward by all these [__] [__] bag
political provocateurs and right-wing
hacks yeah
and I was like is this possible that
this is the guy that's telling the truth
is this possible that sometimes there
was one that I know that had these
strong opinions of you that most of them
at least were like me
they had formed these opinions through a
glance and now I will form my opinions
based on what you tell me
and do no further thinking on the matter
yeah headline someone talking about you
on a on a television show
okay so there's the setup
uh before getting the vaccine stuff
RFK Jr also believes that cell phones
and Wi-Fi are given cancer
that's insanely stupid
that's just this dumbest most I remember
being freaking out about that when I was
a kid
and it's just taking it pretty seriously
and everything I think even like my
parents were like kind of afraid of that
or whatever but um believe that has been
long long debunked well we've been
living amongst Wi-Fi waves
for decades
and I don't see an increase in brain
cancer there's no data
that suggests that it's increasing our
cancer rates none
you know
Wi-Fi radiation well he has a voice
thing so I'll try not to make fun of his
voice
but he I mean I try I'm gonna try
it's just his voice is pretty wild I'm
just warning you guys he has a disorder
so you should not make fun of that
that's what I said okay I was reading
something but I said I'm going to try my
best not to make fun of his voice do
better than try your best just don't
because
yeah your best isn't good enough
just keep your hand on the button okay
I'm gonna do my best Wi-Fi radiation
actually I have mad respect for him
when you have like a challenging
speaking or you sound different speaking
and you still go out there and express
yourself and I I haven't respect for
that because I I go through similar
things I mean I'm a podcaster it's in
front of a camera all day and I've got
Tourette's so
um it's not easy and and I do actually
have mad respect for that so good for
him
that being said you're [__] [__]
does all kinds of bad things including
causing cancer
Wi-Fi radiation causes yeah from your
cell phone I mean they're cell phone
tuner tumors you know I mean I'm
representing hundreds of people who have
cell phone tumors that's a lie here it's
always on the ear that you favor with
your cell phone that's a lie oh he says
he has hundreds did he say his hundreds
back it up
cell phone numbers behind the ear it's
always on the ear that you favorite cell
phone tuner tumors you know that I mean
I'm representing hundreds of people
hundreds he's lying you don't have
hundreds of people suing
for having ear tumors from cell phones
that's just [__]
Chachi BT overwhelming scientific
consensus based on extensive research is
that the electromagnetic radiation
emitted from Wi-Fi devices within the
established safety limits does not pose
a significant health risk to humans
I've talked about this before but the
wavelengths coming from
our household and common devices is
nowhere nowhere near powerful enough to
modify our DNA or to cause any changes
to our body or cells our
DNA history for that to happen you would
need like Gamma or not gamma you need
the Ultras it needs to be ionizing
radiation the type of radiation that
comes out of Wi-Fi and cell phones not
even close in energy levels not even
close that kind of radiation comes from
like the sun comes from outer space it
comes from x-ray machines it comes from
nuclear [__] Fusion like it's not
even close you guys lost the Sun from
being home yeah the the bandwidths are
between the
part of the spectrum that like TV and
radio broadcast would be and where like
microphone or a microphone microwave uh
uh part of the spectrum is so I mean
we've been blasting radio signals for
hundreds of years bouncing around our
atmosphere amongst all of us it doesn't
damage us fifth generation 5G cell
phones are anticipated to use the
frequency spectrum of 80 uh gigahertz
these frequencies all fall in the
non-ionizing range of Spectrum which is
low frequency and low energy the energy
is too low to damage DNA
just doesn't happen see him Best Buy is
like [__] Chernobyl I know right
we gotta seal all the best fights up
with with iron domes
on the ear it's always on the ear don't
come to my LAN party bro
with the amount of land Parts I went to
as a kid I should be dead by now
like back in the day like an old Russia
there was that uh nuke uh nuclear plant
that blew up like what's the name of
that
you know what I'm talking about right
yeah
I remember that great HBO documentary
semi uh real yeah whatever
now that I mean I'm representing
hundreds of people who have cell phone
tumors he's a liar he's alive he might
be with yourself representing about
hundreds of people who are claiming that
but also 100 people who has cancer on
their ears not that much it's like
not even like a a thousands of percent
of people using iPhone and stuff yeah
but the fact that he somehow found uh
he's he's lying
oh um and you know we have the science
so if anybody lets us in front of a jury
it will be over you know it's like what
is what is the number because a lot of
people there's a lot of people because
if we sat in front of a jury it'd be
over dude it's been decades science
where's the jury he's got the science
and so this is Joe Rogan right he
doesn't push back he's not it's hard to
push back on people like this full-on
conspiracy theory nuts because again
they just say [__] they just say [__]
and they say a lot of [__] and so to
actually
um debate someone like this successfully
I feel like it would be impossible if I
didn't have like a team of people fact
checking everything they're saying in
real time
because you otherwise you would just get
railroaded uh into Oblivion because like
unless you have a photographic memory
and you know everything
you know
uh how do you counter just someone
saying a bunch of [__] especially when
they're like smart and they look
like he he has a or Aura of like
professionalism
this is as close to a royal family as uh
the United States has exactly
well they're glioblast Thomas that's the
kind of cancers that they got
but Cancer's not the worst thing they
also oh yeah it opens up
Wi-Fi radiation opens up your blood
brain barrier
he says cancer is not even the worst
thing somehow it opens your blood
barrier so that toxins uh in your blood
will infect your brain this is uh this
is actually well maybe in his world I
don't know
I mean how do you define worse right
it's all bad
legit I've never heard of leaky brain
blood brain
that is actually uh kind of core I
believe to his vaccines cause autism
thing because I think the idea is that
the Mercury that is in vaccines more at
least older Maxine vaccines uh
bleed through into your brain you get
the same amount you get [__]
Mercury from eating tuna fish dumbass
stupid ass [__] I mean he would
probably say that that's bad too to be
fair to him but okay but everyone's
eating fish everywhere around the world
[__] thousands hundreds of thousands
I am not a doctor an expert for but from
my reading uh the re the that
not all not all Mercury there's
different types of mercury and the type
of mercury that's used in vaccines is
not the same as the type that gets into
the water supply and winds up in fish
um it's a metal huh it's a metal mercury
is Mercury
uh it's literally on the periodic table
Yeah but there's different like Isotopes
and different
compounds whatever
but uh
so you think that it does cause autism
no you no no no no I don't think I don't
think Mercury I don't know if maybe
maybe taking a lot of mercury can cause
autism I don't know but I know that
vaccines have a completely negligible
tiny tiny tiny amount of mercury that's
similar to eating you know Seafood now
if you now they also recommend for the
record that you shouldn't eat a certain
amount of
large fish because you get too much
mercury you're not supposed to eat like
swordfish more than like a few times a
month because there's so much mercury
right so yeah that's the thing is it I
just looked it up the the Mercury that's
in vaccines isn't just pure Mercury it's
uh like an organic compound
based on Mercury
um so
but like I said they're not it's it's
and it's probably a different kind of
compound that's in Seafood
the amount of mercury in uh
uh vaccines is literally negligible okay
thank you now if it crosses the blood
brain barrier yeah so what is that
there's current we asked chat gbt
I've never heard that phrase before
there's currently no scientific evidence
that suggests Wi-Fi radiation opens or
disrupts the blood brain barrier the
blood-brain barrier is a protective
barrier that separates blood circulation
from the brain and central nervous
system its purpose is to regulate the
passage of substances between the
bloodstream and the Brain to maintain a
stable environment
for proper bearing function so it is a
real thing yeah your blood brain barrier
BBB
is a tightly locked layer of cells that
defend your brain from harmful
substances germs and other things so
he's saying the wavelengths are
scrambling our our bbbs is penetrating
our Shields
that BBB is [__] then if you can't
handle a little couple little
wavelengths I mean that [__] comes from
space every day dummy stupid ass
maybe your BBB is [__] up but I don't
know what you've been doing
weird [__]
I mean it was his aunt who was
lobotomized
uh uh that would be yeah yeah you're
right got him so so that was your aunt
who got lobotomized you want to talk
about breaking the BBB
that breaks right through it
all right listen to no [__] oh if
anybody was a surprise jury they it will
be over you know it's like what is what
is the number because a lot of people
there's a lot of people with it skinny
says if it's so negligible
then why does it cause autism it doesn't
that's why
that's what I was just want to be clear
it doesn't
vaccines do not cause autism
period zero percent chance
thank you
now I'm saying if you feed your newborn
baby swordfish for every meal I don't
know what's this going to do to him
don't do that by the way either
that'd be a bit extreme just to be clear
yeah fly a blast Thomas that's the kind
of cancer is the thing yeah but cancer
is not the worst thing they also you
know it opens up
Wi-Fi radiation opens up your
blood-brain barrier I can't imagine
that's worse than cancer but okay
whatever
who cares yeah it's not the it's not the
Pain Olympics uh Joe is initially
skeptical but does a rigorous fact
checking by having Jamie Pope a website
buy a crackpot org that works with RFK
Jr Environmental Health Trust which
repeats the same claims Joe is convinced
we got to get rid of Wi-Fi good luck
with that one bro
that's awesome he wants to get rid of
Wi-Fi so what do you think Wi-Fi is
doing to us since it's everywhere and
how does yoga convinced of something so
obscene so World chattering if you're
willing to believe that Wi-Fi is causing
people to get cancer and breaking our
bbbs our big beautiful bbbs
how are you so willing to accept that
premise man that's a big life that's a
whole paradigm shift in your world
understanding since everyone's
experiencing including you what do you
think it's doing yeah I think it
degrades your mitochondria
and it you know you think brain barrier
you think see this is what I feel like
I'm good at it's like you think that
you're just saying [__]
I think Wi-Fi makes my [__] dick hard
yeah baby I Crank It Up when it's sexy
time I crank up my Wi-Fi all the way
dude in a way it does
yeah I guess so it's true all around the
world men are getting hard because yeah
thanks to their Wi-Fi on a daily basis
usually around 12 a.m when the family's
asleep oh yeah oh yeah
oh
do you do you see anything online I
could open up your blood brain barrier I
don't know about how but I that it does
I mean I don't I found an article I was
trying to find the validity of it but it
has a statement on here
damage the blood-brain barrier radio
frequency radiation exposure has been
shown to effect and disappointed in
Jamie on this one the permeability of
the blood-brain barrier probably because
he typed does Wi-Fi break the BBB and
then of course yeah nobody will be the
top result yeah it's going to be his I'm
looking into that uh word right now and
it's
interesting I'll I'll report back you
look into what
this organization that he's citing for
all these stats and that he works with
yeah yeah got you here as well as
altering the expression of micro RNA
within the brain which is like whoa
that's crazy and then rfk's like yeah I
wrote that
I was like oh that's not a good source
if you just wrote it
torture State could lead to adverse
effects such as neurodegenerative
disease whoa
how come we don't know that exactly good
question Joe follow that logic why does
nobody know this why does it lie that's
the problem you get the tingle of like
this makes no sense
but your conclusion from there is not
the right one
what's more likely that this guy's full
of [__] or that we're all walking around
getting cancer of our brains from Wi-Fi
that's been around for like a hundred
years plus expanded on researchers in
China and there's a published article
here but I was looking around at the
page
they call it leaky brain
the findings were followed by
suppression what did he say they call it
leaky brain whoa don't make fun of his
voice that's just that's what he said
leaky brain that's kind of funny nobody
calls it that
I don't know that there's a doctor that
did a study the doctor uh oh yeah that
was my best body uh
he goes by auntie fouchy
and said that it's been expanded on
researchers in China and there's a
published article here but I was looking
around at the page
they call it leaky brain the findings
were followed by suppression
misinformation and a shutdown of
government-funded research in the United
States is the same as same play
oh we gotta get rid of Wi-Fi
what the [__] Jamie
they're all come on you will not be
getting rid of his wife of course not
but why are you even pretending to be a
[__]
RFK Juniors claims are a bit different
from the covid conspiracy content that I
usually watch because at least John
Campbell Brett Weinstein Etc are
churning out fresh [__] every week
rfk's
and vaccines called autism theory has
been debunked for decades that's the
Mercury that's the compound so he's way
behind he's not even up to date on the
new talking points I've been hearing the
Mercury or the vaccines cause autism
things since I was a kid like this is
this is not fresh material for sure you
know I had I heard a really good theory
for why people believe that it's because
when you're
when you're vaccinating your children it
is really traumatic right and it happens
periodically like every six months and
uh autism starts to express itself
around the time around the times when
that's happening and when when children
develop autism there's a thing called
regression where they they're fine and
they're normal and that's how you
perceive it and then when they start
exhibiting
um signs of autism they start regressing
regressing and their social aptitude and
stuff and though so they go oh he was
this way and then he got vaccines and
now he's regressed after that and now he
has autism so it appears yeah and it
typically happens uh
typically happened between 15 and 24
months which yeah is when you start
getting your vaccine time and I even had
that uh you know when I was getting both
my kids vaccinated because you go in
there and they give them like five six
vaccines at a time it's pretty crazy and
I was thinking like man if he if one of
my boys right now started to develop
regress and then develop autism I could
see why big time people would be like
these [__] vaccines did this to my
child like I could see it like it's so
it's right there it's so and it's and
it's so heartbreaking to see your child
even autism doesn't mean any you know it
doesn't mean anything about the quality
of life they're going to have but like
just to see something happen to your
child sometimes it does it depends on
the severity well and I could see how
that'd be scary too because especially
that young like you said with the
developmental stuff because you're
saying like you know they're starting to
talk they're starting yeah yeah yeah or
whatever and then suddenly that that
goes away that's that would be scary
it'd be heartbreaking scary you're
looking for answers so I like I was
right there and I imagined it and I
could feel it you're like [__] it was
these this goddamn vaccines I wish I
never got them
I totally understand it
um yep I think that's why despite being
debunked for a long time and being
around for decades at this point again I
remember I remember hearing about that
when I was a kid
I think that conspiracy theory was
starting to come about
and um yeah I mean a lot of people still
buy it
it's sad but uh it's just not true
unfortunately
Ethan please stop saying develop autism
you're born with it or not well you okay
fine I mean listen around the age when
you start exhibiting symptoms of it what
do you want me to say stop it
give me a [__] break huh
but they developed some uh
pissed off feelings if you don't stop
start being nicer to me whoa
I hear it
was it Carlos who said he couldn't
heal autism yeah Carlos heals autism
yeah yeah yeah he cares it
it's my favorite
but here it is anyway I guess his
Central conspiracy theory is that the
CDC commissioned a study by verse stray
10 which found that the thermosol and
vaccine causes autism okay wow that's a
study I haven't heard of so CDC hired a
um uh Belgian epidemiologist named
Thomas verstrad
and they opened up the vaccine safety
data link which is the biggest
database for vaccines for hmos all the
the top 10 hmos have all their records
in there so they have all your
vaccination records and all your health
claims so you can do these kind of
cluster analyzes
and verse radden went in there and he
looked at one thing he looked at
children who got
the hepatitis B vaccine within their
first month of life
and and compare those Health outcomes in
children who did not in other words
children who got it after 30 days
or didn't get it at all that was the
second cohort
and what he found in his first run
through the data let's pretend he's here
and he's telling me this [__] let's fact
check what the [__] he's saying because
it sounds like a giant pile of bull crap
is there was an 1135 percent greater or
elevated risk for an Autism diagnosis
among the kids who'd gotten that oh hold
on Emily's uh now she's mad that I I'm
just kidding Emily we're friends don't
worry I'm just kidding okay thank you
what that's the girl who said uh in chat
oh that you just yelled at that I just
yelled at you it's okay love you no hold
on well I love you no homo okay
in their first 30 days
at that point they knew what caused the
autism epidemic because a relative risk
it's called a relative risk of 11.35
irrelevant risk of two is considered
proof of causation as long as there's
biological plausibility
relative
um
Amy's having trouble uh understanding
what he's saying the fact check him
ableist I understand what he's saying um
devastated yeah I probably need a little
bit more time to figure out what he's
talking about so um maybe we can loop
back to that later I'm not gonna just
look at this [__] he'll do it
damn
yeah stay in Belgium Belgium study
let's see uh
uh research gate that sounds like a
scandal
here he is
currently uh
Florida thing thought yeah well I'm
trying to host a show it is that's why I
said let's come back to it give me give
me a little bit to read up on us getting
a pack of cigarettes today for 20 years
and getting lung cancer is 10.
this was 11.35
like he's just saying [__]
he goes yeah there was one study
commissioned by the CDC 20 years ago
that proved autism
uh happens from vaccines no other study
since or from then though
just this random guy
I mean dude
and then nefariously conspired at a
conference called simpsonwood to cover
it up and they would have gotten away
with it too if those pesky jrfk Jr
hadn't exposed them by publishing this
transcript of the meeting
sounds gossipy juicy oh there was a
panic throughout the industry that you
know as people heard about this study
the CDC I wanted to do a meeting with
all of the big pan jerems of the
industry
they didn't want to do it on CDC campus
because then they thought it would be
subject to a Freedom of Information law
requests they wanted to do it just keep
it secret
so they they found this Retreat Center a
Methodist Retreat Center in norcrosco
Georgia called simpsonwood and they
assembled I think there was 72 people
giving a Bohemian Grove ocdc NIH FDA
um
and all the vaccine companies
and all the big academics the people who
basically develop vaccines in the
academic institutions and they were all
there
and they spent the first day they they
give them all a copy of the first round
study but they have to give it all back
because they don't want it out there
and then they spend the second day
talking about how to hide it and
um how do you know this because somebody
made a recording of it and I got a hold
of the transcript so you got that so you
didn't hear the recording you saw some
words on a piece of paper
that somebody sent to you how do you
know this uh somebody I know
somebody I know sent it to me and I
published excerpts from those
transcripts and rolling stone and
anybody can oh
again he's the king of just saying
things
uh here's the article from a decade of a
go over these claims this person wrote
it says in summary no the veristatan
study doesn't show that be rfk's
evidence for the grand conspiracy at
Simpson what is one out of context quote
oh is that right
yeah whatever
a the general theme with all of RFK
Junior scientific claims are he takes
correlation and observational studies
especially pre-controlling for uh
confounders to be conclusive evidence of
causation but he ignores studies that
show he is wrong or claims they're
fraudulent
typical uh basically
if you actually look up the studies he
mentions it's trivial to find how he
absurdly misrepresents them he claims
that a burbacker study shows uh femoral
salt only appears to be processed out of
your bloodstream because it accumulating
in your brain
he did the same study and then an NIH
actually then commissioned a study
and they because they at that point they
were really trying to figure out you
know whether this was dangerous
and they commissioned a very famous
scientist called Thomas burbacker up at
the University of Washington Seattle
to do a study with monkeys with macaques
and he did the same study pichiara did
but he did something he can't do with
children which he then killed the
monkeys
and then he looked for the Mercury and
what he found was the Mercury yes it
left their blood immediately the Ethel
Mercury from the vaccines
was gone from their blood in a week
of Mercury from the tuna fish was there
to my a month later two months later
but when he sacrificed the monkeys and
did postmortems
he found that the Mercury had not left
their body
instead the reason it was disappearing
from their blood is because
F of mercury crosses the blood-brain
barrier much easier than methylmercury
soaked up that was good how do people
[__] listen to this this is so
[__] boring dude yeah the monkey's
brain sucked up the really juicy from
the vaccine but the tuna fish couldn't
do it
couldn't break that BBB
yeah dude he is the king of just saying
[__] but so what we do when we prepare I
I doubt he'll come on it would be
awesome though is you know it because
these people have dialogue trees that's
also what's so
good in my opinion about debating these
kinds of people is because they don't
speak genuinely they don't speak from
the heart they're on talking points and
whenever whenever they go and talk about
it they say the same thing so it's super
easy or not super easy it's a lot of
work but it gives you the ability to
research all of his talking points
before he comes on
uh because again he's just on a dialogue
tree like all these folks
you know
the study Compares thermostat
to organic Mercury and finds a much
lower brain concentration of total of
mercury it was reserved in the
Moroso monkey compared to the
uh yeah
he claims uh yeah whatever bro I don't
know pandemic
okay well whatever he does this whole
show with Joe and he's just saying [__]
and uh Joe's just listening and not
challenging him at the least bit okay so
that's where the Story begins
now let's move on to the really insane
part
um
well I guess maybe this we'll just watch
this one here or maybe we have watched
it we watched that one yeah yeah so um
here's an album
of tweets that took place
after this podcast aired so this guy uh
Professor Peter hotz
he's a MD and a PhD
and I guess he's like a he's a doctor
that specializes in vaccines I don't
know his credentials I've seen him
before uh his credentials are that he is
the dean of the national school of
tropical medicine and professor of
Pediatrics and molecular virology and
microbiology at Baylor College of
Medicine which is in Texas he helped
develop uh it's called corbavax which is
a non-patent uh covet vaccine with the
intention to give that to poorer
countries sounds like a real piece of
[__]
and uh and important to the story he is
also a former guest on The Joe Rogan
podcast several years ago yes so he has
he knows Joe he's familiar with Joe
um Joe's familiar with him and that kind
of leads us into what happens now okay
so he tweets this out Spotify has
stopped even sort of trying to stem
Joe's vaccine misinfo it's really true
uh tag this person it's just awful and
from all the online attacks I'm
receiving after the subsurd podcast it's
clear many actually believe this
nonsense did they mention him by name or
something why was he already getting
harassed well I think he is
uh you know a popular Target in this
whole thing yeah
so Joe responds to him Peter if you
claim what RFK Jr is saying is quote
misinformation I'm offering you a
hundred thousand dollars to the charity
of your choice if you're willing to
debate him on my show with no time limit
so it calls him out why is he like well
I find it weird that he's putting money
on the table from the beginning because
why not just a civil invitation be like
why don't you I'd love for if you guys
want to come have a conversation that'd
be great that's a great Point yeah like
it's already somewhat combative for the
get-go well I guess maybe he
uh I mean I mean he's probably heated
from what yeah I tweeted yeah the
professor came out hot
yeah okay so a hundred thousand dollars
and by the way people always do this
it's so stupid it's like just donate the
money Joe you [__] [__] if you care
then they go you hate charity
through you hate charity Elon actually
says that can you believe it Elon
responds with the flame Emoji fire
freaking fire happening right now and
then Elon hits him with the with the key
is that a keemstar line maybe Peter
Holtz just hates charity okay bro you're
the richest person in the world just
donate whatever you want like what the
[__] you're worth like 200 billion shut
the [__] up dude
you literally own this entire website
that you bought with cash
I think you hate charity because you're
not donating a million dollars every
second
uh oh now uh RFK enters the mix Peter
let's finally have a respectful
congenial informative debate that the
American people deserve
Theo Vaughn is in the mix now
why is there so much I had to include
that just so that uh we could see what a
dumbassi is
sorry Theo's cool he's just a dumbass
he's getting swept up he's proven the
dark arts man no I want I won't say
anything Theo's a good guy I won't say
anything bad about him
you have a problem with theobon
yeah he uh he thinks that vaccines cause
autism
what if I told you we had the same
birthday
don't care about that at all do you know
do you know he thinks that or is you
just basing it on this I'm just basing
off of that I don't know anything about
his beliefs
you can infer what's going on here maybe
he doesn't maybe he wants him to debate
him because he's such a big fan you know
that he wants to just come slam RFK man
that might be true actually so I mean
this guy is being straight up dog piled
by like the most famous people in the
world on Twitter and invited into like a
super hostile environment I know I don't
think Robert F Kennedy would be uh
hostile I mean but the
the atmosphere is certainly pretty
hostile
um
Spotify this is the original tweet he
did
uh Elon responded to it he says so
you're saying you endorse Vice
wow you are dumb as [__] so
because
he likes this one article written by
this one author then he has to endorse
whatever [__] article this is by
different Arthur posted on Vice
right Columbia donkey [__] well hold
on I've seen that that was just a video
about how people there's like a TR like
a group of people in Colombia that have
sex with donkeys it's not an endorsement
of it
right it was interesting I don't know if
you guys saw it this Elon endures
everything that's on Twitter
uh yeah he does apparently
yeah apparently like it's in this area
of Colombia it's normal for like young
men to lose their Vint virginity to
donkeys
out there
just the right height
uh Elon continues to be the dumbest
person in the world with like literally
12 year old talking points he's afraid
of a public debate he says
because he knows he's wrong I mean dude
grow up
love you no homo there's a million
reasons why this professor might not
want to do a debate maybe he's not
confrontational maybe he's not good at
debates Maybe
he knows like we've talked about that
just one dude up against uh
a misinfo God can never you can never
hold him down he knows all this stuff
so Professor responded to Elon Musk so
seriously Elon this is monstrous 200 000
Americans needlessly perished including
40 000 Texans our neighbors because they
were victims of anti-vaxxed information
during our awful covid waves in uh 21-22
please don't do this
uh Elon responds
first of all I'm generally pro-vaccine I
vaccinated against all uh everything and
my kids too second I think there's a
tremendous promise and synthetic M RNA
that said the world obviously went crazy
with excess vaccinations against coven
19. quote unquote I have that in quotes
because the RNA sequence changed wait
why so much that I called the virus of
these thesis Theseus like the ship of
Theseus meaning it's not the same virus
that it was originally because it's
mutated so much that's wonder why the
flu
wonder why but like that's pretty normal
for viruses like the flu
the flu shot do you think the flu shot
is a conspiracy
because that's literally what the flu
shot is so many people I know had
serious side effects from the vaccine
including myself shut up I went and
looked it up
because I was curious It's like I didn't
know that has he ever mentioned that
before
on his second booster when Elon got the
second booster he felt really shitty for
a day yeah me too me too yo we need to
talk about this that is not
a serious side effect my friend we need
to talk about the serious side effect
like feeling icky for a day like what
they tell you you're gonna feel right
now even even if it's more than feeling
icky even if you felt like [__] you felt
really bad that's still not a serious
side effect 200 000 people you didn't
have a stroke you didn't have a heart
attack
you felt like [__] that happens when you
get vaccines if you weren't a total
[__] idiot you would understand that
yes 200 000 people died but I felt icky
for a day can we talk more about that
please
failure to acknowledge that is a lie as
for the deaths you claimer due to
covid-19 why is the nation of Sweden
still alive
um
how can you be this dumb I mean
seriously Sweden did have a lot of
people dying of kova 19. uh it's not the
bubonic plague
we know that it has a mortality rate of
like one percent also in Sweden I think
people were Max they were vaccinated
there
yeah they just didn't lock down right
love yeah no lockdowns right yeah the
vaccine was prevalent they just didn't
lock down so what the [__] so what are
you even talking about
yeah just go on Rogan and do the debate
why aren't we dead yet
nice meme
uh he is such a piece of [__]
here is Gillian Roth uh I agree with the
same Elon my kids are on the Spectrum
shots did not put them on the spectrum
they got it from me but in regards to
the vaccine I was told if you have
autoimmune not to get it I was told it
would be like gasoline on fire yeah I'm
well who's this person talking about
yeah I'm still being bullied Elon
responded exactly two of my kids are on
the Spectrum and they got it from me not
vaccines okay what are we what what is
that how's that relevant it was obvious
from when they were babies but
thankfully improved to somebody what the
[__] are we talking about
okay that your kids have he goes yeah no
my kids have autism nothing to do with
the vaccine it's like
okay
Elon Musk Joe Rogan and RFK doing more
to dismantle big Pharma than any
politician in the history of the United
States combined I wonder if any of the
politicians that are constantly crying
about big Pharma role and [__] up
this country will come to their defense
I wish you all actually cared about big
Pharma and would do something to
regulate the prices of Medicine
instead of just like or the opioid
epidemic or like yeah I mean
there's Nuance here right it's like the
pharmaceutical industry it does do
shitty things absolutely like and is
responsible for a lot of anguish
uh in this country but to write it off
wholesale is
foolish I mean
obviously obviously their drugs work
right yes like drugs work right like
they make drugs and we take them and it
works yes yeah
that would be weird if they didn't I
think we would realize I think the the
problem with the pharmaceutical industry
isn't the pharmaceutical part it's the
industry part it's the business part
yeah
to be frank we're lucky to have modern
medicine I'd be dead from malaria if not
for a chloroquine and uh doxycillin but
we should still question medicine rather
than consider it sacred the entire
Foundation of science is to question it
we did we do there's so many studies
people took this seriously for a while
like the the autism thing and it's it's
not true it has been questioned
uh so Tom said about this some guy he
said no medical profession should ever
agree to this never it elevates the
conspiracy guy that means the medical
profession and will only convince the
Kooks out there that RFK is right
because a real doctor took the time to
debate him now this premise I personally
disagree with but I understand where
they're coming from if you're equipped
for the debate and you can
expose them and maybe you can fully
disarm them and expose them then I do
think it's good but again it's hard if
you're not fully prepared then then yeah
it can backfire and I mean it's
like debate is much more about rhetoric
than being right at the end of the day
and I can understand somebody not
feeling confident enough to go debate a
[__] Kennedy yeah you know yeah in a
hostile environment on a platform that
that is friendly to him and hostile to
you he's a scientist he's not like a
Entertainer he's not that's what I'm
saying it's just like not everybody is a
debate Lord not everybody is going to be
willing and and nor should they be or be
expected to be like that's not the Forum
oh well so this is and he said I would
do it
he said he would do it separately he
said he would come on a show and talk
about all of this in great detail but he
didn't want to debate he didn't want to
because
yeah that means Fair
but Joe didn't want to have that he said
that would be a great suggest Joe said
this that would be a great suggestion if
you could assure that the industry you
are representing wasn't completely
captured by heartless monsters who have
a history of some of the biggest
criminal fines in human history because
they're just shut the [__] up bro you
don't know anything I'm such a sucker
antidepressants usage in and of itself
says a lot Global antidepressant users
per I don't even know what this what the
source of this is so I'm not even going
to take it seriously
and what says what
what is it saying that in America uh
people are over prescribed medicine is
it that we're over prescribed is it that
people are happier in what are people
happier in South Korea
assuming this is accurate you're right
you could extrapolate a lot of different
uh things from it including societal
Norms it says it all concluding uh
people's relative Quality of Life
Society you know
uh it doesn't really say it doesn't
speak for itself right
there's an argument that says ssris
outweigh the positives oh my God also
Iceland is the second one on there and I
thought I remember yeah icelanders are
ranked
the third happiest populace in the world
let's go rounding out the top three
behind the uh the the fins and the Danes
that would play into their argument
because they say it doesn't matter about
the relative happiness it's just they're
trying to sell us [__] we don't need
but wouldn't that okay yeah
there's a lot of layers to this isn't
there but now Elon Musk is saying uh
ssris aren't good
bro
he is a [__] demon man
Joe Rogan grills Dr Peter Holtz for
exclusively promoting vaccines while
disregarding exercise vitamin healthy
diet man he did not do that I guarantee
he didn't do that there's a large body
data that connects poor diet to a host
of disease you don't think vitamins are
needed while you eat junk food he did
not do that there's no chance he did
that
he's like get vaccines but don't
exercise eat vitamins or healthy
he's like don't do that that [__]
doesn't matter
this
pediatric doctor
zero percent chance
I just upped The Joe Rogan debate
offered a 600 000 for Hots to debate RFK
okay cool just donate the money
are you sure I'm not part of a coalition
with neo-fascist leanings you might be
seems like that's why you really think
or what you're projecting to the masses
he tweeted out
about Tucker Carlson now he's defending
Tucker Carlson
the professor said uh
I'm quite concerned about the Elon
Tucker link then fold in Rogan and RFK
Jr and it becomes a pretty formidable
Coalition with neo-fascist leanings in
some ways darker or perhaps more
dangerous than Trump in my opinion awful
I just hope team Biden is preparing so
he's political nature I see why Joe's
getting pissed off about it
he's right about the first part and Joe
is definitely not preparing
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and make that
guess right now so he offered this to
Rogue he said I'm happy to come in and
clear the air I respect you and your
show I don't want to adversarial
relationship I think we can all work
together well to those misunderstanding
what he's saying he's not agreeing to
debate Robert Kennedy he's just offering
to come on my show that seems like a
good he's so heat about this Joe Rogan
does not tweet very much and this he's
like this is Mega triggering to him
let him come on and talk about it
I'm sure people would want to listen to
that too debate
uh Joe says
professors said to Joe Joe if you're
serious about addressing vaccines plus
the fact that 200 000 found vaccinated
Americans needlessly perished because
they fell victims of vaccine information
I do want to have this discussion Joe
said again I'm going to ask you very
clearly are you willing to debate Robert
Kennedy Jr on my podcast
I find it so [__] funny that this guy
Robert Kennedy is like their Messiah
this is the guy that everybody's afraid
to debate
uh I am we're inviting him on my show
on our show to debate and I'm just a
[__] dumbass
like I am the biggest dumbass in the
world I'm not a professor
uh by any means not even close [__]
Joe you have my cell you have my email
I'm always willing to speak to you
professor said this is a non-answer said
Joe I challenge you publicly because you
publicly quote tweet and agreed with
that dog [__] Vice article if you're
really serious about what you stand for
you now have a massive opportunity for a
debate that will reach the largest
audience
by the way uh doctor I saw this tweet
that you deleted
oh he's really [__] pissed he's
really
leaning tipping triggered
Professor tweeted this out be serious
Joe that's what you throw out for your
Hunting Buddies on a weekend
oh he said about the hundred thousand a
50 million endowment which used Spotify
RFK can easily afford not for me but so
we can continue making low-cost patent
free vaccines for the world's poor
preceded by JFK
jrrfk's public apology I mean he's not
wrong he's like if you want to put some
money let's do something that actually
affects something
you know
Yeah a hundred I don't think they're
doing that I mean he's not wrong and
same with Elon a hundred thousand
dollars is like [__] Pocket Change
literally
so okay so they had this whole heated
argument of and them all just ganging up
on uh the professor
and oh here's what he said okay this is
good he said that now in that tweet that
Joe Rogan retweeted
they said he said don't exercise he was
downplaying the importance of exercise
and nutrition let's see care of your
immune system in other ways do you take
probiotics are you cautious about your
diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm a junk foodaholic uh
actually well that seems like a terrible
thing for your health it is a terrible
thing yeah
he's a person he knows it's not good for
him he's a [__] person that likes
doing [__] Joe you smoke cigars yeah
it's like and you consider yourself a
health nut not you I call you you eat
junk food which it's it's fine smoke
cigars enjoy them it's I'd like that's
not a problem but like what is this
gotcha is so stupid yeah everybody makes
bad choices sometimes
so working on it but that seems
ridiculous for someone who works with
health yeah yeah is it really is it
really and this he's a he's a you can
tell he's a mild-mannered
a non-conventational guy you see how
he's talking a joke because like someone
else would be like what the [__] does
that have to do with anything right I
know it's healthy but I'm a human being
I like doing [__]
yeah um yeah I like junk food it tastes
good he's just taking it right sometimes
he's like yes I get it right he's
wearing a [__] bow tie what how often
how often do I steal a bag of chips or
something like that garbage uh Joe
thinks the fact that he eats Lay's chips
debunks his whole life story
caught you this [__] Lays
eat lays don't get laid
got him
oh
wonderful no no hopefully not every day
but you know maybe a couple of times a
week oh Joe's really nailing down Rachel
my uh my daughter with autism that's
like our thing is to go to the uh it's
called The Burger Joint or to um Shake
Shack to get a to get a cheeseburger
because he said his daughter has autism
did I just hear that go I take it all
back the vaccine guy
gave his daughter autism he's been
experimenting
delete the episode so you live in large
we call it like that mouth pleasure so
much you're willing to sacrifice a
little bit the fact that Joe thinks he's
doing something here is stunning
the man looks so excited to be there
he's like yeah I'd like to take my
autistic daughter out and share a
hamburger and Jill's like you you
[__] idiot I got you [__] I got you
what do you know about hell I got you
[__] hold on let me light up this Cuban
hold on if you were a serious doctor if
you were serious about your field you
would never eat a hamburger with the
autistic daughter ever
this is gonna make me cry it's really
sad so what about bullying him oh he I
feel like he's bowling yeah I don't
trust a doctor unless he's Jack right
yeah that's true unless he cruises
through the the
uh unless he cruise to the grocery store
shirtless right like a meat MD or
carnivore MD yeah they have no
credibility I have to concede that's the
case well there's I mean I don't have to
tell you but there's a large body of
data that connects poor diet to a host
of diseases
yes wow you just blew his mind Joe
he didn't [__] know that
the PHD MD didn't know that
that seems like a crazy decision your
line of work there you go sometimes the
uh
my mind is my thing about this not all
brain it's uh it's something else but I
mean he doesn't even know what to say
he's so sweet sweet dude Joe's like come
back on so we can bully you more
he's not
sorry
I'm sorry this is oh my God go give this
man love I swear to God well it gets her
even sadder when you see that people are
going to his house now yeah you'll see
if you ate healthy food I mean the thing
is your body starts craving healthy food
you start feeling yeah no no questions
no question about it do you take
vitamins I don't take vitamins really
yeah wow I think they do I don't think
they're neither because most in the
American and the American up hold up
hold up okay first of all he's right but
the whole vitamin if you want to talk
about
the um
the pharmaceutical companies selling
this [__] we don't need don't even get
started on the vitamin cup people like I
don't think there's any like really
strong evidence that even concludes our
body can metabolize that [__] hold up
you don't think they're needed while
you're eating junk food well hopefully
I'm not only eating junk food but you
know there's a yeah you never said this
body of clinical research on the
efficacy of vitamins especially vitamins
D vitamins I have taken vitamin D for
periods the recommendation of my
internist and what about fatty acids
which are great for your brain this is
literally the dumbest line of dialogue
Joe can have I mean he what is this in
fish oil and just a reminder Joe Rogan
retweeted this because he thought it was
such a slam dunk this is proof that this
doctor downplayed the importance of
exercise and nutrition different things
that are fantastic I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna argue with people
you got it you got you got it over me
yeah you gotta listen but it would you
would have a much better argument you're
making my wife stay here you're taking
care of yourself a hundred percent
I'm speechless yeah
because everyone takes care of
themselves 100 or none at all I'm
[__] speechless
every doctor uh what what is this take
but you still need your vaccines I'm
sure you do but vaccines aren't going to
prevent cancer no that's true right
that's true there's a lot of diseases or
diabetes or cardiovascular disease and a
lot of these diseases are connected
directly to diet right yeah yeah
what are you doing he didn't say he said
he has a hamburger once in a while man
that's all he [__] said
I'm such a sucker the man says I go to
shake shack with my autistic daughter
and you tried to [__] unravel him
with his sweet little bow tie around his
neck yes how could you even see this guy
and be like I'm gonna bully the [__] out
of him
like the thought of him getting ready
before the interview like all I can see
is him being like
and he's like this is a short excerpt
I'm sure it was like a three-hour
episode I know but this is in the back
I'm just trying to make you not cry
Olivia I'm sure they had a productive
conversation cry you should cry I will
I'm gonna do it this is 4 21 seconds the
Joe retweeted
sedentary life I try to go on the
treadmill for 30 minutes I do it
actually I'm pretty good yeah
why don't you just go for an actual walk
it's more interesting I do that too Joe
why are you being such a judgmental
[__]
what is your problem dude
I can't get over this
okay so you guys get the tone of this so
Joe Regan uh Joe Regan
Joe Reagan am I right
Joe Reagan yes that's good got him got
him mine are better than that
if you're are you making fun of my no I
don't know no Joe Reagan
got him
[Music]
I'll put this offer out I'll I'll donate
a hundred thousand dollars to a charity
of Joe Rogan and Elon I'll give a
hundred thousand of both you guys for a
chair to your choice if you guys come on
my podcast you [__] hate charity I'll
do it cash hundred thousand I think 100
hits charity because I don't think he'll
accept I don't either that's the only
conclusion you could draw Elon Musk
hates charity standing off for Elon
clearly you just hate charity bro I'll
do it hundred thousand each boom boom
uh
uh and so that is all that's happening
yada yada uh
must change in that Holtz would be
afraid
uh we kind of already covered all this
in the album I think so here now this is
where it goes off the rails yep uh on
Sunday Father's Day
independent journalist Alex Rosen filmed
himself outside of hotz's house
asking why he wouldn't debate
uh check it out
shows the show can I even I mean this is
still up and has 20 million views so I I
don't think it'd be an issue to show it
to you
um
I mean I don't think so I mean there's
not really anything to identifying I
don't believe so
I mean yeah you could you could
definitely identify where he lives from
this it's like a whole front house
but it's got 20 million views and it's
pinned so it's like
I think it's really relevant to see what
[__] site I don't think any of our
fans are gonna follow this guy you know
what I mean I would hope not
um I have
let's watch this I have an unbelievable
twist that I just learned about the
story that's gonna blow your mind okay
so this giant piece of [__] Alex Ross
and apparently Rosen Rosen uh he's been
he went to his house and by the way here
he is celebrating that he blocked him
let's go I got blocked by the guy who I
who I'm like uh
uh stalking
so here he is on Father's Day taking a
walk like Jill told him damn take a walk
and here he is taking a damn walk oh are
you Peter
I am hey nice to meet you how are you
hey so why are you not like gonna debate
uh RFK on Joe Rogan's podcast oh come on
that's harassing I'm just I'm just
curious what I know nothing hostile just
curious I haven't said anything one way
or the other
I mean are you planning on doing it uh
it just he just invited me so we'll see
oh and I think you should though uh well
we'll give it some we'll give it some
okay
and now he's going back into his house
because he's Disturbed right and what do
you have to say to people who think
they're a vaccine injured
anything for them I don't
know I mean do you have anything to say
to people that think father you have
anything to say to people still smiling
yeah
I mean do you think that controllers are
real Peter
Peter it's just a question because out
of breath
I wonder how many walks he does
science now
hello and here he is laughing and so
this is so great it's pinned it's
getting tons of a now before Elon Musk
bought Twitter this would have been
removed for harassment right like no
question I'm surprised that this video
stayed up it's got 20 million views
none of them [__] care are you ready
go ahead
same guy
oh no it's the pedal Hunter
okay because I remember when this guy
pedo hunted EDP then everybody started
canceling him because apparently he's
also a creep and a big piece of [__] uh
yeah he ended up getting banned off of
YouTube I'm seeing uh let's see after
exposing EDP a lot of controversies came
out about Alex Alex was called out for
his older prank videos where he called
black lives mattered hotlines and
repeatedly said Rachel slurs against
African Americans some videos saying
racial slurs homophobia being creepy to
a decoy
um talked about having a three-year-old
female child in his basement
uh Chet's Behavior was called out by
mudahar and Charlie for his older videos
the brain Trend he had his channel
terminated off of YouTube So yeah so
okay I'm not surprised this guy uh did
that
yeah I just looked up his name and the
EDP thing was actually the first thing
that popped up so here you go uh Elon
Musk who was like I'm cool with this
kind of content on our platform and
here's the kind of other more tweets
that are being targeted at him
um sorry but I don't trust any medical
advice from someone with teeth like this
I think he has cute smile I think he has
the most adorable I think his teeth are
very endearing to be totally honest also
I didn't say anything about the adorable
hat he was wearing in that video it was
really really really cute and I'm sure
it protected him really beautifully from
the Sun yes like I genuinely think he
has a very nice smile very sweet smile
let's see your smile DC Drano I'm sure
it's Ugg dumb ass love ya no homo so
this is now this guy's life is basically
he's being relentlessly harassed both on
and offline
and uh well I really think that
um Elon and Joe are
just despicable disgusting vile people
bullies bullies yeah of a sweet guy
who's dedicated his life to Public
Service medicine chip for children and
apparently
a vaccine that he did not uh
IP protect so that he could give it to
poor countries
you
oh he went on uh Maddie Hassan show
okay let's see what he said this is
correct RFK Junior another anti-vaxx
nuts have claimed there is no connection
between vaccines and autism no
connection no established documented
connection between vaccines and serious
diseases or mass death that seems
pissed aboard
do evidence
only shows shows does it not and people
are dying right now from covid still
because the evidence on Covert vaccines
efficacy is being ignored or shouted
down on social media
well there's there's three three or four
moving parts to this so um I've been I'm
a vaccine scientist I make low-cost
patent-free vaccines for low and middle
income countries what a demon
huh I said what a demon oh oh I love
them so much it's also obviously part of
like the Jewish agenda or something
he's sending vaccines to third world or
not third world but under developing
countries
oh it's to like sterilize them yeah
right no which all of these people are
very paranoid about uh happening is he
what he's really trying to do is break
down the blood blood brain here knock
down the better yeah
beautiful brain big beautiful babes so
that uh when they use cell phones their
brains Get Zapped harder priests are we
made a hundred million don't you find it
suspicious that this guy RFK Jr it's not
just one conspiracy he's interested in
it's like a whole bunch of really [__]
up ones like if you just maybe compared
about one yeah just cared about one
maybe more credible
but they need to talk about more people
living in the center of the earth who
are secretly stealing people from
cornfields
this is uh we made two vaccine
prototypes that led to 100 million doses
being administered in India in Indonesia
no patents minimal strings attached so
we actually found a way to bypass the
Pharma companies and yet RFK Jr
incessantly calls me a pharmaceutical
when if anything our vaccines may be
kept Pfizer and modern out of markets in
India and in Indonesia exactly that's
why I don't yes he pointed that out
because I was thinking that the whole
time like when I found out that he's
Behind These patent-free vaccines it's
like shouldn't he be
celebrated by like the anti-farma people
like that's a really good point yeah
really good point Dan that piece and
then I the reason I got involved with
RFK Jr in the first place is I have uh
an adult daughter Rachel who has autism
and intellectual disabilities and wrote
the book vaccines did not cause Rachel's
autism that refuted all of his false
claims and and and that's been you know
he's been uh oh my God it's Cheryl
Sandberg his wife is the Le is his
Larry's ex-wife and curb yeah that's
crazy what the [__] have they been
married the whole time during curb I
know they got married in 2014 and I
think Cheryl's character oh actually I
don't want to spoil anything
I'll text you you're not gonna spoil
curb you're worried about spoiling curb
I guess it was like a decade ago now
it's not like a who died the divorce in
this show I think was 2012 so
but she was still on the show so
there was right yeah
all right yeah ever since then and now
he's at it again and but this time you
know Elon it's it's the steps sorry this
time Eddie it's it's caused something
really terrible and that is during our
coveted pandemic I have a new book
coming out that basically says 200 000
Americans needlessly perished because
they believed the anti-vaccine
disinformation and refused to take a
covet vaccine during her Delta wave and
be a one in Omicron wave in 2021-22
after vaccines were widely available so
the point is anti-vaccine disinformation
it's always done a lot of damage and
harm but now it's a lethal force in the
United States and that's why we that's
why we have to have that discussion and
I offered to come and talk to Gonzo
Rogan again I've been on a couple of
times and have that discussion with it
but not to turn it into the Jerry
Springer Show with having RFK Jr on Fair
that's a good point
it's not about confrontation if you want
to talk to him talk to him now I am the
Jerry Springer Show that's why I love
this shirt you know what I mean
in fact hit me with the Bell Zach
oh one sec
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're so it's it's sad because I said
I'm so fed up at the debate me debate me
uh because it's not really about the
debate if it was about finding out
information as you said you've already
written about vaccines and autism you've
already spoken and written about covid
vaccines I think you've been on MSNBC
and other channels hundreds of times
since the start of the pandemic people
can hear your views and the evidence you
bring to this so they're not actually
interested in evidence and it sadden
means that you're a man who basically
has saved lives abroad with the vaccines
you've developed whereas RFK has
contributed to a culture of vaccine
misinformation culture that has led to
the deaths as you say of hundreds of
thousands of lives and yet he's the one
being celebrated by Tech billionaires
like musk and Jack Dorsey while you're
being smeared and defamed and I would
say I don't know if you're ironic or not
my advice the guy who's actually working
selflessly to improve the world is the
bad guy and Elon Musk
and uh Jack Dorsey the billionaires
who have [__] this world in the ass
are the good guys I'm good I just dug up
Cheryl this is from last year my
husband's reference to Anne Frank at a
mandate rally in DC was reprehensible
and it's oh what she going after her
husband yeah what did he say about how
sweet is me this has been deleted but uh
the atrocities that Millions endured
during the hall guys should never be
compared to anyone or anything his
opinions are not a reflection of my own
how is how what how are they married I
could pretty much infer everything that
happened from that tweet he was at some
rally and he was saying that yeah like
mask mandates are the equivalent of the
Holocaust what did he say about Anne
Frank though
let's see I gotta know how do you go
home when your wife just like called you
a demon on Twitter I don't know it was
like what was it was the couple the the
woman that worked for Trump and then her
husband was like a republican yeah it
was like the most outspoken like and I
always wondered like how the [__] do you
guys have a relationship yes well it
didn't seem very good because I remember
their daughter
having a really hard time all right and
it was all that wasn't good it seemed
really unhealthy are you talking about
kellyanne yeah kellyanne Conway yeah
kellyanne there it is yeah is this what
he said uh is this the quote
maybe yeah this is it even in Hitler's
Germany you could
you could cross the Alps into
Switzerland you could hide in an attic
like Anne Frank did Anne Frank literally
died
right you forgot that Anne Frank was
taken to a concentration camp it was
right like Anne Frank did Kennedy said
in a speech I visited in 1962 East
Germany with my father met people who
had climbed the wall and escaped met
people wait hold
the [__] phone how old were you
you didn't mean [__] dude in 1962 you're
probably like a two-year-old no he's
probably no he's a good memory no I
think he's older than you think
what's his birthday
he was born in 1954. he was eight years
old
that's pretty young
I bet you can remember stuff when you're
eight I visited 1962 East Germany with
my father and met people who had climbed
the wall and escaped so it was possible
many died true but it was possible so
he's saying
at least in Nazi Germany when you were
when Jews were trying to be eradicated
from the planet they had more options
unlike the mass mandate where you know
you know options not
what a [__] idiot go hide in the
Attic great analogy even have your mind
go there it's so [__] stupid like
it's the mask mandates like the least it
like nobody [__] enforced that [__]
dude nobody cares but the the even the
the victim mentality it takes to compare
what Anne Frank did hiding in an attic
for years
her whole family was killed including
her
um to being asked politely to wear a
mask to go on target
and like most likely if you said no the
Target employee being like okay it's
fine yeah it's fine yeah just her dad's
like at no point was the [__] gestapo
[__] tackling you to the ground for
not wearing them just like Nazis it's
just made up just like Nazi Germany
crazy
yeah so we I really want him on the show
oh my God imagine being married to
someone who said that she can't what how
are you married to him Cheryl she said
my husband's reference to Anne Frank at
the Mandate rally was reprehensible
dinner later
what on Earth she's not Jewish is she is
she Jewish she might be honest I don't
know
Larry David's not Jewish yeah he is I
know I'm kidding what the [__]
the joke dude uh
Cheryl Ruth Hines I mean Heinz doesn't
sound she's race Catholic yeah no I
didn't think so no you never know you
never know
you know they walk among us
you never know you never know in the
words he's in Hollywood right I think it
was fresh and fit although I don't
remember who said it they're like yeah
you could run into a Jew and never know
it
I think I was having preaching yeah I
think or that's what I meant to say I've
been preached whenever we talk about
burning the witch oh no not the witch
the only era where we used to burn the
witch
that Aaron never really stopped right
the type of witch we was burning changed
well said well said my man
so yes I want to reach out emphatically
to our boy Robert I gotta be frank with
you but
I don't think he will accept no of
course not but let's try and then I'll
put money on the table and then accuse
him of hating yeah of hating charity
there you go yeah
we'll get that we'll get them yeah
we'll get them I mean we're gonna come
up with some really fancy beautiful
words
he seems amicable he seems like a nice
guy quote I mean civil and he seems open
to be having conversations so I don't
think it's I don't think it's super
impossible I feel like because he's
running for office his team will look
into us and tell him not to do it
right that's unlike Joe Rogan who's
never have been in a controversy well
all his controversies are things that he
likes so
right I like your controversies not
yours yeah
I mean I never made I mean the Anne
Frank joke he made is more [__] up
than my Ben Shapiro joke oh his wasn't a
joke
right he was serious
so there it is pretty depressing stuff
from Joe Rogan and Elon Musk wow they
are really [__] pieces of [__]
I think at the end of the day the
message is this
[__] you no
we need to look to our Guru Timon and
hard times like this yes five things
that I want you to remember every day
okay don't chase anyone don't beg anyone
to stay know your word
save space for people who matter and
love yourself
just what I needed to hear honestly I
literally that's for sure no homo all
right before we go let me see if I got
any other messages from my doctor I can
give you guys okay while you're doing
that why don't I bang out some of these
chats
yeah I could just shout out real quick
that ELO has a new Vlog up oh well
yes sir buddy oh did she just mention
that uh Lena just sent the chat here let
me pull it up actually that beginning is
really funny it has uh Oliver
oh trying to steal a bunch of [__] from
the office like I'm sure
uh while you're pulling that up Veronica
donating 50 bucks and set my golden
birthday is next week my golden birthday
what's the goalie birthday but you'll be
on break 28. that's the golden birthday
says who oh wait is that when it's like
the day of the month okay when you turn
yeah the age that you're okay [__] you
there you go uh wait can this is a big
request here uh can Ethan do a Helen
Keller or Southern style happy birthday
what is a Helen Keller you're not
touching it you know what no no he can't
forget I ever said that why don't we do
a southern happy birthday for uh
Veronica you can do a southern happy
birthday for Veronica I don't know what
that
come on down there how about yourself a
nice old birthday down there bar tell
you what man find yourself a donkey and
just kind of have your way with it boy
I'll tell you man ain't nothing like
that donkey [__] there you go you did
it that's good ain't nothing like a nice
warm donkey [__] on your birthday
well Veronica also said they bought
heavy fresh for their birthday and using
this chance to shout out uh BB no money
Oliver tree and young gravy shout them
out just shout out to them shout them
out let them know yep
just like Anne Frank uh torb donated 20
bucks and said man Pearl really likes
printers yep that was a while ago
obviously but that's that's a fact she
really likes what
what'd you say pearl
you said Pearl really likes what
printers okay
no we're on the same page you can yeah
we can move on
could that have been misinterpreted
somehow no um I just
yo Max donated 20 bucks and said Zach
cheers my dude you're on fire today
cheers congratulations again Max love ya
I don't know if that's it Max but
congratulations to the other Max yes uh
also donated 20 bucks a hey 42 months
give me a shout out what the [__] 42 42
thank you dude that that is up there
holy [__] do you see if there's any
other big ones I want to get Luke
donated 50 bucks and they didn't say
anything they just want to give us 50
bucks
maybe they donated later and
no they didn't they just gave us 50
bucks hell yeah Luke okay okay
thank you uh the devil actually called
you out at one point
um again during the RFK thing and said
you were uh
you're acting from a place of emotion
when you were getting worked up okay
shut up you want to come on the show and
debate need devil
oh and but then the devil donated
another 20 bucks and said uh on Joe
Rogan uh Straight to Hell going straight
down okay
that's fair uh Mr Magic donated 20 bucks
and said H bomber guy has a video about
the origin of vaccine to autism pipeline
that I could not recommend enough uh
yeah I watched that video uh many years
ago when he first released it and it is
a banger
that channel is really good yeah bomb
them and uh Laura gave 20 bucks and said
your shirt is so fire Ethan oh thank you
I'll tell Teddy tell Teddy I'm gonna
show Teddy the
the show when we get home let's see
yeah
um can you give him a cheers my dude
from me cheers my dad cheers my dude um
another one the devil just kept donating
20 increments uh so thank you for that
but then they said Daniel is the biggest
hater that's me
all that goes through his head is the
demise of Ethan Klein and the guts theme
on repeat yeah yeah okay thank you
somebody's finally saying that
I feel
yeah Ethan is kind of my Griffith
you know
I'm guts you're Griffin no you're you're
a Griffith no you're a Griffith you're
[__] Griffith dude oh uh speaking of
anime I actually wanted to ask you we
were talking about it before the show
did you see the trailer for The live
action one piece okay I'm avoiding it
okay you haven't watched it at all no
because how it's gonna be so bad so what
we were discussing is
there seemed to be a consensus Among Us
that it looks dog [__] but none of us
know one piece and online the reception
to it was actually I watched the trailer
or am I gonna get claimed
um
check it real fast I'd love to do a live
reaction oh my God that's Luffy
no way it's good even if you know the
story
why does he look like that okay you know
what I'm not gonna I'm not gonna okay
let's I really want to watch this
trailer now well and he's working on it
the things the story is so long how are
they gonna even adapt it
I mean I'm sure you know seasons do it
in arcs I I assume one piece has like
arcs right yeah yeah so probably just
take on
the Dragon Ball Evolution thing maybe
where they just completely [__] the
story where they just completely change
everything yeah God I really want to
watch this I hope we can watch it please
let me watch it
um
yeah it seemed like the the one-piece
fans uh weren't totally hating it is
whatever that right and but um all of us
that have not watched the show going in
blind it looked pretty crappy I mean
every real I don't think there's been a
single
real uh IRL adaptation from anime that
wasn't the worst thing ever like yeah
see in our own chat I'm seeing a lot of
people it doesn't look that bad it
doesn't seem that bad it looks good like
what name one that wasn't the worst
people are saying it's lore accurate uh
Luffy is that the guy's name yeah is he
supposed to be Brazilian because I guess
that actor is Brazilian so oh maybe it
is Brazil doesn't exist in the [__]
one-piece World well then never mind
nothing about one piece like I said I
don't know jack [__]
Luffy is from
where is he's from the East blue isn't
he where is Luffy from he's from fuchsia
Village yeah but it's in the uh
uh what part of the world is it
which country which country is Lucy from
Brazil what the [__] are you talking
about the actor
yeah he's from the East blue
Dawn Island
[Music]
they've been split into four quadrants
East blue West Blue North Blue South
Blue
it goes from the East blue it got
glammed Ethan damn
sorry
why do they do that I'm trying to
promote your show morons I don't know
why they put claims on trailers that
will never make sense to me just seems
like more eyes on it the better right
like the production quality looks kind
of good
uh yeah there's Parts where they're like
on the boats and stuff and uh you know
it looks it looked like a pirate movie
it's whatever you know what I mean the
thing is it's such an anime it's I don't
know how you can convey it there's a
there's a part at the very end that
I didn't really understand why this was
happening but it it looked pretty
[__] goofy I hear which part keep
going further to the end oh like uh like
after the like the Stinger after that
that was just right here I guess it's
right there
oh great oh it was right before that
he stretches his arms like stretch oh I
want to see it that's his power yeah
okay he's like he's a gum gum what it
looks doing it looks absurd it looks
well that's what I'm saying it's anime
you can't make this not look stupid as
hell
all right this is already too much we're
gonna get claimed here's the thing
here's my problem thank you here's the
problem I'm not gonna do it I'm just
gonna show you here's my problem with
anime adaptations
they try to make it look like the anime
they shouldn't do that because it looks
dumb as [__] if you try to convert anime
tropes into real
real people doing it you have to adapt
it to make it look like
reasonable believable they always do
this it's so dumb looking
um somebody said the author ascribed
them theoretical ethnicities and
nationalities that are not present in
the verse and I guess that is where the
Brazilian uh
thing came from all right yeah
I don't even know what that means it
seems silly but maybe maybe I don't know
anything
because Luffy's relatives are
whatever who cares
um okay I'll try it I'll enjoy watching
it yeah we got yeah oh it says no impact
though it got claimed but it says no
impact
oh so maybe that's okay look at that
here the Odo is the uh Oda is the author
says if you become a member of YouTube
program this claim may affect your
ability to monetize the video but on it
it says no impact
um
do we love it just watch it after the
show no impact it why even risk it
um
we're at three and a half hours you're
gonna risk three and a half hours for
foreign
oh [__] this you know no
no
just now my dude no my dude all right
anything else we're reading uh
reading stuff let me see if there was
any other big fat ones sorry to anybody
else I'm skipping over or there's just
there are hundreds here and we'll be
here all day best girl's basement said
um oh the the author said Luffy's from
Brazil Nami is Swedish
Nami has red hair
is there anyone in Sweden with red hair
probably yeah yeah yeah all in all over
Europe Zorro is Japanese Sanji is French
I mean okay
I understand I'm saying like that's an
archetype but again
whatever okay I'm not gonna debate
[__] one piece lore right now
I don't have the credentials for that
either yeah I'll show you guys at the
beginning of this y'all can go watch
Ila's uh vlog
a little teaser
what is he doing baby I don't know I
just saw him outside big fam hey Gila
all right I don't know if you remember
me
[Laughter]
they gave me the codes last time I was
here what's going on
just wondering if you know Ethan
actually owes me a little money I've
been doing some basically just showing
up doing a couple videos dude that's not
true yeah
and he's offered me a little bit of cash
but I'll take uh how much does he owe
Travelers checks or if you guys know any
kind of check really would do you have a
yeah
uh it's just like north of 200 000.
that's not true you guys had some money
from that lawsuit right no it looks nice
paying a lot of money I'll take two of
these three of these yeah you guys
should check it's very funny he tries to
steal a bunch of [__] it's it's a whole
it's a whole thing and then here's a b
submitting him
thank you AB for that anytime
it's it's very funny what a frame it's
really good but okay um thank you
everybody a great show here shout out to
Pearl shout out to uh shout out to the
Kennedys shout out to the Kennedys
should we reach out to that sweet doctor
maybe he wants to come on yes
I'll tell you that right now oh my God I
would love love to see you guys yeah
let's reach out to uh the wonderful
doctor yeah let's give him a pleasant
place to put his bow tie
you know yeah
he deserves the reception well reach out
to both of them and then what we'll do
is have them both call in at the same
time Stephen Curry Joe Rogan sidelining
dude that'd be awesome [__] you Joe that
would be hilarious
here no I won't do that to you Doctor
whenever
all right guys thank you for watching so
we only have one more
uh Cheers episode on Wednesday
and then or I guess I have the members
tomorrow so remember tomorrow Wednesday
off the rails no show Thursday and then
Friday is the big night
the big night everybody it's gonna be
awesome on Fridays the the show starts
at eight right it starts at eight
o'clock Pacific time for people at home
ideal for fans in Europe
um but that's just the way it goes all
right Zach's play me off
um Zach really wants to get out of here
apparently all right thank you everybody
I want to thank God I want to thank uh
the Almighty I want to thank my parents
I wouldn't be here they did their best
Cheers thank my wife who has supported
me through everything I want to thank my
kids who uh are there they love me
cheers my dude love you no homo
[Music]